benton yeah let's talk about your
hydrated body
okay how hydrated is your body my wab my
wet ass body
i'll tell you something hydrant is this
powder
that's like an electrolyte powder that
you dr mix directly into water i don't
know if we're going to lose the sponsor
but i'm pretty sure cardi b and megan
the stallion
it has to be when i was hydrant i love
this product because i know that i'm
drinking like healthy refreshing water
because i have to mix it with that
little packet my brain's like this is
kool-aid
it's got sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc and here's the thing i'm just gonna
you know me i go off coffee i'm
authentic i
heard i hate i hate the taste of water i
never drink water the only time i will
drink water
tell them if i'm lying okay okay i'm
ready i take these little packets
they're called hydrant packets i do the
fruit punch
yeah i like the sweet tea lemonade
because i like the south i like the iced
tea flavor
you know sweet tea is a full thing
and i put it in my water bottle and then
just shake it up sorry that was a
very that's a water bottle guys that was
an unfortunate gesture that i just did
if you're watching on youtube
um but uh hydrant is a 100
satisfaction guarantee real fruit juice
powder delicious
refreshing special deal for our
listeners to save 25
on your first order drink hydrant.com
whitney enter promo code whitney
checkout that's drink hydrant
h-y-d-r-a-n-t
dot com slash whitney enter promo code
whitney for 25 percent off
your first order drink hydrant.com
whitney
enter promo code whitney to save 25
we thank them for sponsoring the podcast
and making my skin
look so delicious
[Music]
do you think we need to change our open
song is it getting annoying i don't know
i honestly forget
i forget there is one really yeah you
don't listen to the podcast i know
i mean wow rude benton is not a fan of
the pie i just i forget it's there
saboteur i just i did listen to one the
other day and i was like
i was like this is obnoxious we might
need to get into this
2021 new open for good for you podcast
should we take submissions for people
like that you want people to
to like send in their own ukulele covers
like we could just have like fan
submissions for a new open
yeah you know i like that okay let's get
on that
um all you musical uh
dandies i know nothing about you all
your friends like we don't do music it's
not like
not really your thing um okay couple
things uh
today we have a very brilliant
neuroscientist on the podcast
i'm so excited for you guys to hear this
episode it's truly
three and a half hours so we're gonna
have to make this open very short we
have a couple announcements to make
um it's an incredible episode just
because this is what i want to do with
the podcast i want to have these
amazing scientists on and doctors to
sort of give people um good hard science
you want in free health care
free health care the government won't
give you health care but good for you
will i we cover everything from you know
how to get out of
unhealthy relationships you know why
we're attracted
to unhealthy people which we still
haven't figured out on this show
we've been over it a lot and we're still
working on how to get you out and here's
this episode
i'm screwed like
if anyone in this room actually listens
to what dr andrew huberman has to say i
will be doing this podcast
alone uh i don't think it's three and a
half hours because we talked so much on
this podcast about
how do uh smart people talk slow but
what
smart people talk slower what
smart people talk slowly i heard you i
don't know say it again a different way
that's all i know how to say they're
just like they're they speak slower and
more precise and better and nicer than
us
i talk so fast that was the meanest
thing you've ever said so do i i wasn't
complimenting myself
[Laughter]
yes no he's very uh precise and
meticulous and patient
and elegant and eloquent and he puts
everything uh
in sort of words that we can understand
he's also a model
he does look like a scientist from a
marvel movie so this is really practical
advice on how to execute
how to uh have pause how to what he
calls
um have that gap between stimulus and
response how to not say that thing that
you can never take back how to
not send that email you can never unsend
how to not
ben has been with me when i've sent some
texts that i wish i hadn't sent
so it's really about how how to not roll
your eyes or say that cruel thing in an
argument that's going to like screw up
your life so it's really just about how
to have grace
how to um how to be a good person yeah
there you go
from a neural sciences how to be a good
person okay i'm rambling
uh announcements tour
we're going on tour we need some kind of
like
sound effect wait when you just it's a
pain you don't want to talk about your
conversation with the doctor
oh what about it you don't want to
discuss they're going to hear it what
that was like
for him neuroscientist i do but i mean i
bless his heart
i mean the fact that in this entire
podcast you're grinning with this hair
like the cheshire cat
this man is like did i fall down the
rabbit hole
okay so you're literally like a circus
clown talking to this man you're like a
carnie you're like want to toss the
rings he's like what the hell is this
woman talking about
i was like i'm gonna have a
neuroscientist on the podcast i didn't
schedule the hair color at the right
time like
i didn't really think like oh my god i'm
going to be talking to this
neuroscientist looking like elizabeth
banks in the hunger games yeah he's like
how he like willy wonka
and the oompa loompas at the same time
i do look like a johnny depp character i
look like tim burton's nightmare
and i'm just like talking to this
stanford neuroscientist and i'm like man
you're like every pop pop star in like
the second year of their career
i look like cameron diaz and something
about mary when she says come in her
hair
and i'm like talking to this like
brilliant scientist and he's like
treated like a human you're like a
person oh
i'm like the mad hatter over here he's
just like giving me all this amazing
information so
if you're watching it on youtube it is a
jarring visual it's a
it might be a tough watch i really uh
do need to work on um changing my hair
for the next time we have a scientist on
the show
i'm gonna wing get a wig i might shake a
small
black bob um okay so let's uh
now see we i want them to get to the
this interview so we need to shut our
whore mouths
um we're going on tour tours
you've heard about them before well
you've heard about them you've heard of
them getting canceled and i was very
reluctant to book a tour but it seems
like people have finally
figured out how to put on safe shows in
the time
of covid so we are doing five shows
in october you don't seem excited at all
i'm super excited i just wonder what you
did with your hair
i know i just why you did that and
before you made a very serious
announcement i had to look sexual for my
tour announcement um we are going on
tour
with taylor tomlinson you guys know
taylor from she has a special called
quarter life crisis
on netflix um millennial icon you know
her from my instagram because i've held
her captive in my home for the past
three months she's we've become very
codependent during this quarantine so
we're calling it the codependent tour
uh she's super funny we're very similar
don't you think
in a lot of ways like yeah i can see
that taylor tomlinson
is like my twin that i ate in utero
i mean she's shorter than me um so we're
gonna do five
shows we're getting a bus we're gonna do
the whole thing we're gonna go to
escondido california on
friday october 2nd what you on a bus
that's the content people really want to
see
i'm going to get on a bus for you people
i'm going to get on a god damn bus well
my face is going to be on the side so
that makes it a little less traumatizing
uh we're going to be we're going to be
at the westfield
mall this is hard to read these tours
like a fair it's kind of like when the
carnival stops in the mall parking lot
this is so depressing friday october 2nd
the westfield mall
parking lot um wow
let's do some comedy i mean it's look
here's the these outdoor shows they they
seemed very depressing to me i didn't
want to do them either
but a lot of my friends you know bert's
been doing them nicki's been doing them
a lot of my friends
and they say that they're actually
really fun this one is a drive-in an
escondide this might be how comedy is
done from now on you guys i mean comedy
we used to just walk into a dark room
and just
a waitress would hand us a drink with a
straw that everyone had fingered and we
put it in our mouths
and one day we'll be brave enough to do
that again hopefully
so this and i think about it and i'm
like you know what maybe this is how bad
it's gotten since i haven't been able to
stand up in six months i'm at the point
where i'm like you know what
maybe this is better remember like back
when you had to like
drive to a venue and like get out of the
car
like close the door there's a parking
attendant screaming at you you have to
lock it and like
walk up to the front i mean it's like
why get out of the car i'm waiting a
line
yes what a rigmarole you know you'd have
to go and like sit down again
and like wait for you know so this way
you just drive up stay in your car we
yell comedy at you and you can go home
the first show is in cars right wait
hold on i'm dying laughing
wait wait wait sometimes in comedy shows
like if people get sick or something
they'll get up and leave
do you for just me puking on the side of
their car
imagine if someone has to leave the show
early and they're just like excuse me
i gotta head out also who's monitoring
the car you know in a comedy club
there's someone monitoring like what
people are doing like
showing that who can tell you what to do
in your own car i don't know i don't
know this will be an experience
everyone's just gonna be like
furiously jerking off watching the
comedy shows i don't know whatever it is
as long as you do it to me and not
taylor i'll feel okay
um saturday uh october 3rd
denver colorado and this one is not in
cars this one's outside in your own
little
on your own lawn bug spray and your
lunchables
we're having a comedy picnic bring your
hiking boots your flashlights
a small tent is full of soup and watch
them yellow jenkins
one of the yellowjackets have we told
the yellowjacket story on this bike
no so benton was going outside for
something and we have a yellowjacket
problem and what happened
oh no no you skipped the part first off
was not bent and going outside ben 10
was sitting beside whitney and
uh a dear friend of hers who came over
to swim was just
casually walking to the pool and whitney
screams hey hey
wash some yellow jackets in my yard and
everyone was
taken aback because we don't know one
what country icon possessed her body or
what she was talking about
you gotta watch the video let you get
you were so angry
watch the yellow jackets i ain't gonna
tell you again now you get stung i ain't
taking you to the hospital
i swear to god i ain't the virginia and
west virginia in my blood came out
you got to watch the yellow chickens it
was like
okay so when you come to the show in
denver you got to watch the miele
jickets
it will be socially distance it will
also be
emotionally distanced don't you worry
i'll make sure to keep
both types um there's also
going to be another run on the east
coast we're going to cape cod
massachusetts thursday
october 15th to the yarmouth drive-in
this is so depressing we're going to
make this fun come
drive in dry hump i don't care whatever
you got to do
to make this fun friday october 16th
we're going to be
ridgefield connecticut the playhouse
ball field
because this is the playhouse ball field
oh that's triggering for
oh my god comedy i got kicked off the
fuck i got kicked off my baseball
team we need a vaccine they should come
dressed as you and taylor
that'd be fun one and just like uh just
hanging out on your channel
camel toe and high heeled wedge sneakers
pink wigs
pink wigs and just you know like
jimmy kimmel hoodies yeah it'd be great
sunday october
10 18. wait what october nope sorry
10 is the month october 10 18. i haven't
read tour dates in six months i'm very
rusty with numbers
uh the 18th of october will be at
oceanport new jersey
at concerts in the garden well that
sounds bougie that sounds very
fancy there's a garden involved okay so
come to these shows whitneycummings.com
uh
they're gonna be very experimental i
have no idea
what we're walking into but we're gonna
make the best of it because we're in a
pandemic i'm excited comedy in cars
comedy and cars not all of them some of
them yeah the first ones comedy get out
you sit in your cars you bring a little
whoopee is better than your first idea
of comedy on trains
i mean the things that we've been
experimenting with in terms of doing
comedy have been really bleak well he
was like can we do it in a haunted house
what if we get a hot air balloon and
just shout down at you and if we're
mommy just throw knives
um okay we need to get to dr andrew
huberman
can i run a couple jokes first how long
have we gone
okay i'm gonna run a couple jokes okay
so on
friday so if you're listening to this in
a couple days i'm doing a show i'm doing
stand-up for the first time in six
months
on abc uh have not done stand-up at all
and i now have to do five minutes for
uh with for michelle obama
so this is a living nightmare um and
it's uh
uh it's chappelle and uh uh kevin hart
and tiffany yes and uh who else is doing
it wanda sykes uh uh larry david's doing
something so it's like we're doing this
thing to
sort of raise awareness around voting
because people love it when celebrities
tell them how to live
um and so i'm gonna run my jokes for you
because i have not
been able to do stand up in front of
anyone for six months oh for us right
here yes i'm gonna run for you guys
all right ready hi everyone whatever i
say in the beginning i don't know
i'm here tonight to tell you to vote
because as we know from the internet
people are dying to hear what a white
woman without masks on have to say
i like that then why didn't you because
or what about this i'm here tonight
because there's nothing better for viral
content than a white woman without a
mask telling people what to do
i like the first one more okay okay
well i have some work to do tonight on
these jokes
uh so we're here tonight uh to talk
about
voting voting is a lot of work it's just
so many logistics you have to register
you got to go to your polling place
which is at like a high school gym or
like a weird abandoned church just look
at it this way if your candidate doesn't
win
at least now you know where the aaa
meetings are i do like that
okay check check okay you guys you have
to vote you have to vote
supreme court appointments right now are
at stake which means reproductive rights
right so when people say like voting is
such a hassle you know what else is a
hassle driving your girlfriend 350 miles
to plan your family
i love that if you guys got that joke
you're silencing women
um uh to not vote uh
sorry to not vote in 2020 would be
insane the climate is changing at an
alarming rate
forest fires are increasing i mean do
you really want
all of hollywood and silicon valley to
burn down
don't answer that
we have to do something about the fact
that sea levels are rising i mean do you
really want florida to just
sink into the ocean and disappear
these are bad examples
you guys have to vote i love voting okay
and there's more than just the
presidency
at stake on the ballot lots of important
things to weigh in on like i voted
in the last california state election
and now when i
see a porn star wearing a condom i'm
like
i did that that's my voice being heard
that is democracy in action the general
election i love voting in the general
election for me voting in the general
election is like having an orgasm
it takes about three hours and it only
happens every four years
and my options are usually two old white
men
they can hardly string a sentence
together and i always end up with
something stuck to my chest
it's a sticker joke it's an i voted
sticker
it's a sticker joke it's about stickers
can i do that to you yeah i think you
should see is owned by disney
like i do not know oh i have uh hold on
i have some
everything all about his name yeah i
think we're owned by disney um
my hair was done by mickey mouse so
uh let's see well because there's also
people come i'm like trying to come up
with all the excuses that people
you guys are like hearing comedians like
this is the process of like writing
jokes
like another thing people complain about
is like having to wait in line
i want to maybe do a joke about like oh
wait i forgot
i love the idea of you saying do you
want all of hollywood and silicon valley
to burn down
oh they had to like you don't want us to
move where you are like
yeah that's funny oh that's funny then
we'll come move yeah we'll come to you
oh that's great well not me but other
people but there's also um
uh there's an excuse a lot of people say
well oh like my vote doesn't count it's
like
oh really but your youtube comment does
like you know what i mean i won't make a
difference like my vote will make a
difference oh really but your reddit
comment will
uh and then when people complain about
like well there's just like
a line just like you have to wait in
line forever you know what line you're
really gonna hate
the line uh waiting for your handmaid's
cloak
i don't know i like that inside a little
inside baseball
for who people watching that show it's
very popular but there is something
amazing about how americans like i was
trying to write a joke about how
americans like
americans like work very hard we're very
ambitious people but we're all so lazy
about the weirdest things like where
americans start cutting corners is
always so funny to me like
um every contribution we've made to the
culinary arts
is food that doesn't require utensils
it's like hamburgers
hot dogs like we just are just like ah
just like we'll go to war but we're not
gonna move a shelf we have a lazy susan
that's so true like america invented
spray cheese
like we're the people that were like you
gotta cut it then you gotta put it on
the thing like
can someone just spray it in my mouth
like just say i don't have to move my
arms to get the cheese in my
gullet you know it doesn't have to be
cheese just whatever it looks like
like it's neon foam but it's just like
it's just amazing to me like i do it too
because people like you gotta register
to vote i'm the person that will like
go to a website i'll put like nine
things in my cart
and then i'll go to the checkout i'm
like ah never mind you are
100 the person who is like oh i have to
do something to get the thing i want i
don't think so spend an hour like
putting clothes in my cart at a shopping
website i'll get to the end it's like
like uh code on the back your credit
card and i'm like fuck you
never mind like i'll just log out like
my name like i can remember
billing zip code get the fuck out of
here like i just
it's so weird where we sort of um at the
finish line
you know get lazy and i was also
thinking something about um
about how ungrateful it is not to vote
that would be like
marrying a prince and then leaving the
royal family
okay don't get on meghan markle's bad
side
i don't know whose side that's on i
can't even tell anymore
who are you roasting that would be like
marrying the prince of england and then
moving back to america
and if you move at the castle bobby i'd
be like being
yeah i don't know i can't really figure
that joke out that would be like adele
marrying a deaf person
i guess that's not really the adele joke
now that she's done those that hair
style on
that just set twitter on fire number one
trending
number one is your niecy nash our queen
uh
oh there's something of like people say
like i don't need to vote it won't make
a difference all right well i put on
makeup every day
does it make a difference it's sad but i
do
i scribble eyeliner on every day just so
that
kevin 492 from iowa can say
don't hate it yeah and then i go to his
profile and it says proud father what
the fuck
just saw a proud dad be like you don't
need that makeup
just said that a proud father can be
like you're so much prettier without
makeup you're so funny show me your
boobs
okay love you guys enjoy dr andrew
huberman
such a treat uh dm us all the stuff that
you learned
like subscribe oh oh like subscribe
comment also send in your um
make sure to how about they send those i
guess text whitney on her little number
thing
little number thing that little thing
you do 818-239-7527 for tour
updates merch updates and direct
birthday messages from me everyone gets
a birthday message from me and sometimes
benton makes a cameo but i want them to
send you their new song ideas
if they're if they're going to make a
song if you guys want to send new open
song ideas
send them to my number eight one eight
two three nine seven five two seven
i don't know how music it doesn't have
to be that song you make your own song
up yeah
okay you can do a country west we'll do
like a new open challenge type thing you
can do a ballet i feel myself getting
sued like i feel the lawsuit
coming on for what getting sued by
whoever makes this song
well they're sitting on their own free
will you heard it here first that's not
how it works
okay it's called traffic i'm not a
lawyer love you guys
dr andrew huberman i
historically ask 50 times if we're ready
uh my
uh childhood everyone dropped the ball
so i have to ask many many times you
sure it's working you sure it's working
it's just i'm like a broken record
um okay so this is wild
for me this is a very big day for me i
don't get star struck by celebrities i
don't care
i find most of them disappointing
frankly i do get starstruck by
neuroscientists and neurology professors
so
you this this actually is a very big
deal for me
asked the producers i changed did i not
wear a dress and then change into
something else before he got here
yes she did i
put a dress on and then i started
sweating and panicking
so then i took it off and now i'm put a
sweater on which was even dumber
so i'm fully flustered i want to just
say that
out loud i don't get flustered by
celebrities i get flustered by
scientists
people that listen to this podcast know
that i'm obsessed with neurology
um in fact i believe i know more than
you do
and you're very well made and if you
disagree with anything i say i'll just
cut it out
sounds good so this is like a a crazy
honor for me do you want to just
introduce yourself so i don't screw it
up
sure well first of all it's great to be
here thanks for the invitation my name
is andrew huberman
and i'm a professor of neuroscience and
ophthalmology at stanford school of
medicine
so neuroscience unlike neurology is not
the clinical field
so i should just give a disclaimer right
off the bat so i'm not a medical doctor
that means i'm not an md which means i
don't prescribe anything
damn it i'm a research scientist and a
professor so i
profess a lot of things and
people that know me know that this
podcast like this
is fulfilling the promise of what i
wanted to do with this podcast which was
get these brilliant minds
in a room picking their brain i wanted
to be like the robin hood
of science and neurology and um therapy
and
psychotherapy and psychology and stuff
so that uh people could get this
information because i'm lucky enough to
be able to meet people like you and i
wanted to
give them an opportunity to get inside
your head
for free so this is like my dream um
i also just want to say real quick that
andrew was just on
rogan it was a brilliant interview i'm
going to try to not
cover a lot of the same things you guys
talked about this podcast is more
through the lens of
sex relationships good relationships bad
relationships family relationships work
situations sort of how to
edify yourself and all parts um opposed
to like athletic performance or
something we don't care about working
out over here good for you um
but so i'm i'm going to keep guiding
towards that i recommend that everybody
listen to the rogan interview it's
unbelievably
um educational and elegant it's very
rare that you're able to get a scientist
or doctor who is
charismatic and able to convey what they
know in a way that
people that aren't scientists can
understand thank you you know so you
like you make it simple enough for dumb
people like me to actually
understand and i'm gonna you know a lot
of neuroscience we were talking out
there you know a lot about science
and science history i'm not just saying
that like your knowledge is pretty bad
i tru i am obsessed you spend time on it
i it's my heart it's my number one
passion is neurology and and let me tell
you why it's just so we can frame
this podcast in this conversation
because this is like this is such a big
deal for me and i'm
i'm just so excited you know i've spent
a lot of my life
and i'm not gonna say it's just because
i'm a woman i think men you know get
this too we're taught at a very young
age that everything is our fault
and we're taught you know i think as as
a woman you hear a lot relax calm down
you're psycho you're crazy you're too
emotional you're too sensitive
you know i think for the longest time i
didn't really understand why i made the
decisions i made
um i just thought i was bad in some way
and once i started learning about
neurology i actually think it's like a
crime that we don't teach neurology in
high schools to understand how your
brain works and
a lot of the decisions that are made for
you instead of your conscious decisions
um and now you know i think
st learning neurology helped me have so
much more patience with myself and so
much more
uh love and respect for myself of going
like okay
you know i'm really upset in the
situation but that's adrenaline and
cortisol and
you know uh this reaction is something
that would have served me very well in
tribal times like my brain is very well
evolved for
a conflict you know a thousand years ago
but circumstances have changed and now
this tool is obsolete
and even maybe a liability at this point
so
being able to look at your choices and
your reactions and your emotions through
the lens of understanding neurology to
me is just like
the key to being patient with yourself
the key to being hopeful
especially some of the work that you're
doing around neuroplasticity the key to
going like you know what i can change
myself i don't i'm not doomed to turn
into my mother i'm not doomed to
constantly recreate my childhood
circumstances like i'm not doomed to be
in bad relationships forever you know so
to me this is the key to feeling hope
and patience
and self-respect and love so this is
just it's such a big deal for me
well it's the right topic if you're
interested in yourself or if people are
interested in themselves
and or interested in other people what
makes them tick
i mean the nervous system which is the
brain and all the connections with the
body and back again
essentially controls all our experience
i mean everything the immune system
digestion
heartbeat gut microbiome all that stuff
is great and important
but it's actually all controlled by the
nervous system in the brain
and it's amazing how little we you know
it's just so shocking to me that when i
do talk about
you know um i'm obsessed with weighted
blankets and you know whether
it's placebo or not but when my
sympathetic nervous system is activated
i'm like i need to get into my
parasympathetic numbers like what does
that mean i'm like how is this not just
part of our everyday um conversation of
how we
talk to each other yeah so there are a
couple reasons why i think
people don't know more about the brain
probably three reasons one is that a lot
of the best information is recent
it's only really come out in the last 10
to 15 years
the second reason is that there aren't a
lot of scientists who are leaving their
laboratories and talking the general
public yes they're busy
yeah and of the ones that do um they
vary in terms of
how narrowly focused they are or how
much of the field they read about and
understand
um i'm you know part of the reason i'm
here and i've been doing podcast is i
really
i want to be an educator i want to teach
people about themselves and about the
brain
and i think i would like to also put out
the call for more scientists to do
similar sorts of things
and then the third reason is that the
naming is terrible
so as you pointed out it's like
sympathetic nervous system is like
so true it actually is the kind of more
stress-related aspect of the autonomic
nervous system and the autonomic nervous
system which means automatic isn't even
an uh
automatic it's not autonomic and so the
naming is terrible so
medical nomenclature and science
nomenclature
it's designed so that everyone's on the
same page who works on that particular
thing
right and it almost seems as if it's
designed to keep everybody else
out of some secret club but it's not
it's just the naming is
terrible so for those of you out there
that are listening to this
and because you brought it up the
sympathetic nervous system is the
aspect of our brain and its connections
with the body that makes us feel more
alert
that makes our breathing speed up that
makes us kind of stressed and the
parasympathetic nervous system is the
one that makes us more
calm the so-called rest and digest
system is the one that triggers sexual
arousal incidentally so there now no one
will forget it
and literally these are two different
you know your sympathetic nervous system
is just from here
to your navel it's the neurons that
trigger the
all that activation and the release of
adrenaline everything right here
and the parasympathetic nervous system
para just means near
simpa means together so it all happens
at once that's why stress is like boom
you have to know latin in order to
figure this basically out or greek yeah
that's too much
and then the parasite of that nervous
system is the neck it's the neurons that
live along the spinal cord in the neck
and in the pelvic area below the navel
and those control other things right
many other things and so like voice
reproductive behavior defecation
urination
all these kinds of things so but the
naming is just dreadful and so one of
the things that i'm trying to do and i'm
rallying my colleagues to do is to try
and come up with a nomenclature
yeah that can evolve to a place where
more people can understand it right it's
going to take some time
because doctors need to speak dr speak
and scientists need to speak science
speak but
i think it is important today i'll do my
best to not use many
and hopefully no acronyms but we don't
need more acronyms yes
but if i do use them all um be careful
and you do a great job at saying like
the fear center of the brain the reward
center of the brain i try
you know i did a movie on about
neurology and i it took me i'm not even
joking you
a week to learn the word
phenylethylamine
i literally just walked around my house
and like fell out like it was like it's
actually uh physically difficult
it's a mouthful and then you know people
would you know will contact me and say
well you know you were lumping this and
this together
i i think there's a way to have a
conversation about science neuroscience
neurology immunology in a way that
um my hope is that it'll be clear and
that'll also
some elements will be actionable because
i think information is great but there
are
great tools to extract from the field of
neuroscience that people can implement
uh regardless of financial status etc
they can make their lives better
and can help each other and so i i guess
i'm basically saying i agree i think
that
more people need to understand science
i'm heavily biased
in my uh belief in that but um anyway
but i just know i want people to like
because people
often look to me uh as some like mental
health
guru and how did you learn to love
yourself and how did you learn to have
high self-esteem and how did you learn
to
avoid conflict and you know we say a lot
on this show like the only way to win is
to not play don't get into the ring
don't you know if someone asks you to
dance just don't
like all of sort of the ability to
control your impulses
you know is something the ability to
have something that we call pause
the ability to say you know what i'm not
going to engage in this fight you know
i'm not going to respond to this email
right now to not be so reactive because
i think
especially now with what's going on and
we're all at like you know peak stress
uh peak aggravation we're all very
reactive and
you know to me the key to my life having
serenity and the key to me having
integrity and pride is the ability to
choose uh the actions that i take
and before i learned about neurology i
don't feel like i had a big choice i
would respond to that text message
before i thought
i would answer the phone before i was
like do i really want to take this call
like i didn't have the ability
to control my behavior and my reactions
and i would make decisions in you know
with my head
flooded with adrenaline or flooded with
dopamine you know i look at a lot of
let's just say bad relationships and i
look back and i'm like i was just on
drugs
like i look back in some of the
decisions that i made under the
influence of oxytocin
and it helps me forgive myself it helps
me have more patience for the bad
decisions i've made but it helps me as
an adult
go you know what i'm not going to
respond to this email till tomorrow
when i'm not so adrenalized and
activated
and to me understanding the basics of
neurology
is the crux of living a serene
life that you can be proud of that's
wonderful i mean the
the culture around wellness has really
grown a lot which i think is great
the culture and conversation around
mindfulness has grown tremendously we
hear that term all the time
for scientists the term mindfulness is a
little bit um troubling because we
always need to take the opposite so
mindfulness
uh is a great word it sounds great but
the opposite of mindfulness would be
mindlessness
or an and i like to think about things
so
philosophy and psychology tend to be
more about
nouns and adjectives when you think
about biology and neurology it's more
about
verbs it's what you would do because
everything in biology is a process so
like for instance
if you're sorry it just took me a second
i was like verb yeah like verb actually
so all that yeah
yeah so if we were to say um like you
just gave a really nice example of how
do you create that gap between stimulus
and response
i mean viktor frankl talked about the
gap between stimulus and response the
people who are into mindfulness talk
about the gap between stimulus and
response like
be um responsive not reactive yeah
so to a scientist or biologist we hear
that and we go
how how does that actually work like how
would one actually do that because it
sounds wonderful
but then when you get a troubling text
message it's almost instantaneous and
you find yourself actually in the
behavior of responding
so how do you actually introduce the gap
so people have talked about you know
transcendental
meditation and all beautiful practices
but those take a very long time yes
so i think what my translation of what
you just said if i may
is that when one understands a little
bit about their inner workings and the
chemicals and the systems in the body
that cause reactivity i believe just
that understanding of that knowledge can
introduce
the so-called gap or prevent you from
being so reactive
to you but everybody right you included
right from being so reactive
without having to do anything except
just understand that information
that the feeling in your body that you
want to move that kind of like low-level
agitation or jitter or text yes or punch
somebody or whatever it happens to be
that's adrenaline in action adrenaline's
job
was to move your body so it means that
any time that you feel like you want to
do something
you may or may not be in
the best position to do the right thing
so anytime that one feels
the urgency to say something or do
something whether it's a text or to
shout at somebody or to
use if they were an addict or whatever
it is exactly there's a
there's a there's a component there that
i think everybody could benefit from
understanding that's
adrenaline release into the body from
this set of neurons in the middle of the
spinal cord
and that takes half a second wow 500
milliseconds from
when you find get that information to
where you feel like you're going to move
and so
that tells you something you're not
going to put that genie back in the
bottle
what you need to do is learn how to
activate the parasympathetic nervous
system the calming
axis of this nervous system and push
back on that so my hope is that just
even with some information we can also
talk about tools if you like but just
even with information
people will really be able to access the
so-called gap
the the the boundary between stimulus
and response the ability to pause
absolutely without and if you have a
meditation practice or people do that
that's wonderful
and here's what i'll say i i'm a fan of
meditation i don't think most people
have time to meditate
well and there's an additional problem
with meditation too and i'm going to
lose some friends by saying
meditation turns into masturbation well
i wasn't going to say that
i'm guessing sometimes it probably does
but
meditation also heightens one's
awareness of their inner workings and so
the brain has two ways of functioning
all the time and it usually is doing
both at the same time one is called
interoception which just basically means
paying attention to your internal real
estate like what's going on inside
am i breathing fast where's my heart
rate at do i feel good am i happy am i
sad
basically everything within the confines
of your skin
okay the other thing is called
exteroception which is perception of
everything outside you
now the nervous system is always
measuring both to some degree or another
one might be more of our focus than the
other if we see something really
dramatic like if i go and i've seen one
of your shows before i met you i went
we'll talk about that yeah that's right
i was at your new year's eve show i
think it was in portland a few years
back
and so i was fully in the experience of
i was in full exterior
deception but when i would laugh i'd
feel something so it's kind of going
back and forth into reception extra
reception
sounds exhausting it was actually a lot
of fun it was actually a lot of fun
um the and we're doing it all the time
right except when we're in sleep and
then we're fully in our we're only in
relation to what's going on inside us
what if you have night terrors like me
uh it's still only in relation to what's
going on
inside you so you're only enterocepting
but when people meditate
you're increasing that interoceptive
awareness and for people that are
anxious
that may have social anxiety to gain
more awareness of how you're feeling
inside might actually be going in the
wrong direction
because if somebody who has social
anxiety goes to a party where they have
speaking
public speaking anxiety they don't want
to
be thinking about what they're feeling
they want to be out of their head out of
their body a little bit now you don't
want to be so out of your body that
you're not in
touch with your body that's right so
there's a balance there and i think
certain forms of meditation actually
have led to
some uncomfortable states for people
where they can't get out of their head
because they've spent
hours sitting there thinking about their
own thoughts that's right so
i i think there is a place for a
meditative practice i don't want the
meditators to come after me although i
don't feel particularly threatened by a
bunch of meditations
like wobbling in the lotus position with
a pillow i understand there's some very
powerful humans out there throw some
beads at you
that could hurt me that are meditators
and i i do have a meditation
so do i i love it i love that we're
worried about getting canceled by the
meditators
here's i just i believe that everyone's
brain everyone's childhood everyone's
ancestral trauma everyone
are different you know and i think for
me everyone meditating the same way at
the same time with the same mantra it's
just a little silly i think all our
brains
sort of need different things have
different capabilities have different
bandwidths
i tried to do meditation the way that
all the famous people talked about it
for so long it did not work for me i got
bored i got antsy i just was not at a
place yet where i was ready to close my
eyes
for 20 minutes if i did reach any kind
of relaxation i would fall asleep
your brain sort of i think kind of does
what it needs to do
or i was too uncomfortable because too
much pain would come up or emotions
would come up or i was too addicted to
my phone whatever it is
but i did an attachment um a class that
works on your uh attachment strategies
with this guy george haas
and i he gave me a mantra that i loved
which was i forgive you you forgive me i
forgive myself
it's a forgiveness meditation it just
worked for me it helped me like release
resentments and i was able to kind of
incorporate
releasing resentments into my meditation
that's what worked for me
um i'm really inconsistent about it i'm
really imperfect about it sometimes it's
better for me to just like
do a moving meditation walking around
the block you know like i just think
that
um uh i love what you're saying because
a big part of 12-step programs is
service
it's taking the focus off yourself
because we're so self-obsessed and we're
such narcissists and me
me me me and we say your brain is a
dangerous place or your mind is a
dangerous place don't go in there alone
you know so sometimes meditating
is a way to just victimize yourself
obsess more about something strengthen
neural pathways that you should be
weakening frankly
and we should um be doing service which
is like calling someone else and saying
how are you
what's going on with you right because
cooperation and productivity makes
dopamine so go do something else
think about someone else take the focus
off yourself for five minutes because
we get so myopic when we just
self-obsess yeah
too much of our focus is in this
interoception mode it can be
uncomfortable for people
and so and there are people who probably
need to think about their thinking a
little bit more
and probably certain people that want to
think about it or ought to think about
it less yeah
i mean my lab has been very focused on
respiration and breathing and not
necessarily breath work
and not say sitting at corner and
huffing and puffing in breath holds and
stuff
but really just using certain forms of
respiration as a way to control the
state of mind
because it's immediate you don't have to
do any training in order to do it and
it's very powerful for
people to be able to shift from a state
of higher activation and stress to a
state of lower activation and stress in
real time right you don't have to
excuse yourself or take 20 minutes each
morning with a timer right
so respiration and breath work i think
is a very powerful entry point
because meditation used to stress me out
i have to go meditate i have to go and
i'm like the
stress that it's causing me to carve out
time to meditate is probably canceling
out the meditation at this point
and there is a question as to whether or
not a lot of the benefits of meditation
are because of the slowed breathing
and the breathing alone i don't think we
can explain all the positive effects of
meditation through the
the changes in breathing that happen in
meditation but you mentioned walking
meditation yeah so walking meditation is
a beautiful example of
where you're enterocepting you're
thinking about your experience but that
you have to have a certain amount of
extra reception
you know all animals i know you have a
deep appreciation for animals
use self-motion what we call
self-generated optic flow
seeing things pass by their eyes as a
way to calm the nervous system
and that's because when the body is
moving
and there are images flowing by on the
retinas or for blind people out there
auditory scenes so to speak are flowing
by
it actually has a direct calming effect
on the fear center of the brain this
threat detection center the amygdala
this has now been demonstrated in
imaging studies
that and this is the basis of emdr i've
moved into sensitization
reprocessing where the eyes are moving
from side to side that actually is the
eye movement
that is caused by forward ambulation by
walking or by
biking or by running or even for someone
in a wheelchair if they're in a
wheelchair
as long as it's self-generated optic
flow so moving forward and seeing things
pass by your eyes in space
you're quieting the fear centers of the
mind and so that's very different than
sitting in the lotus position
i don't want to knock on meditation too
much but sometimes just getting into
forward motion is one of the best
remedies for stress
and it's an ancient one that all animals
use all animals with eyes anyway
and that can walk they they know
intuitively that when they're stressed
they do things like shake off that
stress and there's a name for that all
that
it escapes me at the moment and they
walk self-generated
so if anyone's feeling excessive stress
yes you can meditate
but that will put you into more of an
interroceptive mode thinking about
what's going on inside you
there's great benefit to just going for
a walk not looking at your phone during
that walk because then you don't get the
optic flow
or a run or cycling it's so basic but it
has a
basis in neurology it actually quiets
these threat detection centers in the
brain
so steal someone's wheelchair is the
main takeaway from this
steal your game people do that in
airports every once in a while i see
them wheel up to the thing and then pop
up and then start walking out
does dr drive do that going for a drive
or
a motorcycle ride or site uh self
motion helps so when you're driving
you're not doing much generally except
um
steering the wheel so it would be best
to do this through some sort of physical
activity it doesn't have to be very
vigorous although it could
but the key thing is self-generated
optic flow so that means being
in bodily motion with images passing by
you on the retina this is
on the retina which is just the seeing
portion of the eye excuse me
and this is what a treadmill in a gym
won't ah interesting
and pelotons and those kinds of things
where you're looking at images of things
passing by
sort of mimic it but you know these are
ancient forms of
we're also looking at a screen which is
a light right
right and you're you're focusing your
eyes into a narrow channel which
actually raises stress levels
anytime your eyes are focused in a small
compartment of space
right whether or not it's a phone or a
tablet or or a smaller room as opposed
to a big vista
you are increasing the level of
alertness in your brain stem through a
mechanism that links the eyes and the
brain stem which is the back of the
brain
if you're looking at a horizon or a
panorama you're
naturally disengaging that and you'll
err more towards
calm and it's the biological basis for
that the idea of if you're seeing
sort of in a panoramic way you're able
to
look for threats you're able to see
everything around you like it makes
sense right when you're hunched over
looking at a small thing
isn't the hunched over position part of
the reason that being on the phone
stresses us out
so much is when you hunch over that is a
a defensive position that
historically um we would be hiding we
would be
being attacked and our body sort of
automatically
goes please do
someone's got to it's uh you're
absolutely right so there are these
defensive postures that all animals
including humans
occupy typically it's going to be spinal
flexion so
you know sorry i think ab crunch as
opposed to spinal extension which
is um more relaxed right the there's a
fundamental question in neuroscience
that my lab and other labs are trying to
resolve which is to what extent is this
stuff bi-directional so we know that
it's bi-directional means um it means we
know the stress response controls
certain behaviors
so let's say the stress response hits my
pupils or your pupils
will dilate which makes us see the world
in portrait mode
right like like on portrait motherfucker
one thing the thing that i like
it's my favorite you like portrait yeah
yeah everyone's a photographer with
portrait mode now
well in portrait mode or when the
there's a certain amount of adrenaline
in your system
the thing that you're looking at looks
very clear and everything else looks
kind of blurry right
everything else fades away this is
tunnel vision and a tunnel vision which
i i just want to like
really dump things down not because
people are dumb because i'm dumb and i
just like to really say things like five
different ways or five different
examples
sometimes um but like if you're dating
someone they come at you what the fuck
was this text
the it feels like the only thing in the
world
right just sort of like that and it is
the visual system
so um the back your eye are these three
layers of cells called the neural retina
they're actually a piece of your brain
that was pushed out of your brain during
development
they're not attached to your brain your
eyes are actually pieces of your brain
they're the only piece of brain pushed
out of the brain
during development out of the skull
excuse me away from the rest of the
brain
and when you stress the pupils dilate
and you see whatever it is that's
stressing you out the text message the
person whatever it is
in sharper clearer focus than everything
else yeah
another thing happens which is your
internal there's like a metronome that's
counting time
metronome is this little thing that goes
yeah excuse me so it's like tick tick
tick tick tick tick i'm gonna subtitle
everything
so everything outside you will seem like
it's moving more slowly when you're
stressed
yeah the internal world will feel like
it's going a million miles an hour
yeah so if you've ever been in line at
the airport and you're late and
you're it feels really stressful the
person in front of you feels it feels
like you're taking forever
it looks it feels like things are in
slow motion you feel like you're in
quicksand or like trying to walk through
mud or something when you're stressed
out right
if you ever been an appointment and you
know you need to leave for another
appointment and you're trying to pay
attention
two minutes feels like two hours exactly
so the other thing that happens is this
hunching prop
posture the other thing is a quickening
of the breathing and the heart rate so
there are a bunch of
things that happen in the stress
response when i said there
there's a big question right now as to
whether or not it's bi-directional what
i mean is
it's unclear still whether or not
changing the way that i
view the world changing my posture will
calm me yeah in general the results
point
to an answer that is yes that indeed if
i'm stressed for let's say you say
something that stresses me out yes
i'll get more narrow focus on you and
the channel of information that's
passing between us
but if i take my vision and i go into
what's called panoramic vision where i'm
just looking at you but now i'm seeing
the ceiling and the floor and you and
everything all at once
that tends to calm me down tends to calm
people down it's not just me right
in general when we release that spinal
flexion
and going more into spinal extension
which means just putting your shoulders
back
sitting up straight it does it has a
calming effect largely because it
releases some of the musculature of the
throat that allows you to speak more
clearly
right voice and intonation is a very
very powerful readout of the stress
response
and isn't this am i going to saying this
wrong the vagal vagal nerve
bagel so the vagus nerve is a is a set
of connections that originate in the
brain stem and neck area the
parasympathetic so it originates here
that extends almost everywhere through
the body
the word vegas actually is related to
the word vagabond it means wandering
wow because the anatomy saw just how
extensive this connection is
and this is the connection to the body
that stimulates the kind of relaxation
so-called rest and digest response the
best way to trigger activation of the
vagus
unfortunately is eating because when the
stomach is distended
it sends a signal that you have enough
resources and it's time to relax
but there's a face that's why we eat
when we're anxious yes nervous
so the most ancient and well developed
and still
very present today form of stress relief
is
ingestion of foods that fill us up
or that trigger the activation of
serotonin
so carbohydrates right right
carbohydrates are the best known
cortisol suppressor
right so this is why people drink
alcohol they eat carbohydrates they fill
their belly they eat
to calm themselves but that response is
actually very slow
the the fastest way that i'm aware of to
calm
the nervous system when one is stressed
is to use respiration breathing
but to use a different connection that
runs down the other side of the neck
which is called the phrenic nerve
p-h-r-e-n-i-c
unnecessarily complicated unnecessarily
complicated but if you want to look it
up
and you're using an f you're doing it
wrong it's ph
that's the only reason i spoke with an f
like it's just y it's a really
interesting nerve connection because
first of all it's a very fast pathway
the vegas is slow
yeah vegas is like is like walking on
the shoulder of the freeway
that the you have to get someplace
that's going to be slow whereas the
phrenic nerve is a very fast pathway
right so that's breathing
that's the fast lane and that's
breathing and there's one pattern of
breathing in particular that all animals
use i'll reference animals as many times
because i i adore animals and animal
behavior as well
which is the physiological psi so you
you literally have a set of 200 neurons
and it's
not a hundred and it's not a thousand
two hundred neurons in your brain stem
that control a particular pattern of
breathing that you do anytime
oxygen in the environment is low or this
thing called carbon dioxide which makes
us wanna breathe and stresses us out
right that's too high and that pattern
of breathing is two inhales
and but let me ask you something i'm
really gonna get granular on this
i've been told that i breathe wrong i've
been told i breathe from my chest and
not my stomach
okay where is the oxygen coming from
exactly when you do those inhales
okay so let's talk uh we'll just discuss
the neural circuits and anatomy of
breathing for
two minutes in a two-minute thing with
no acronyms i've been told
at 37 years old i was told the other day
by a trainer that i don't know how to
run
that i run wrong and i was told that i
breathe wrong
but it's a lot of it is performers we
have to hold our breath for a real long
time and then we let it go so i can hold
my breath for way too long right and
opera singers are
spectacular at the controlling the
system as well
so all right so the neuroanatomy and
anatomy of breathing in two minutes or
less
you have two centers in your brain one
controls rhythm rhythmic breathing
rhythmic means inhale follows exhale
falls inhale paul's exhale just like day
follows night
this area if you want to remember it
it's called the pre-bot singer complex
but the best way to remember it is it
was named after a bottle of wine
by a very prominent and important
breathing researcher at ucla named jack
feldman
anytime you're breathing inhale exhale
inhale exhale you're using
the what's called the the wine center of
the brain just
the winery center the other breathing
center
is it's called the parafacial nucleus
that doesn't matter but the reason it's
called parafacial
is it's it's an area that controls
breathing that violates inhale exhale
inhale exhale allows you to inhale twice
exhale twice
inhale three times the reason you have
this area in your brain and everyone has
this area in their brain is because you
need to coordinate breathing with
speaking
so when you're on the example you just
gave is perfect when you're on stage and
you're
you're about i don't know you're making
a sprint towards a
whatever you call it a punch line i'm
out of my wheelhouse it's like
what is it our terms are way more simple
than yours yeah a joke a set up a joke
a joke i've heard of these jokes
you guys should take a hint from
comedian so there's a latin name name
i'm just kidding
so the you have this brain center that
controls non-rhythmic breathing
they both control a really important
muscle
in your belly called the diaphragm and
the important thing to understand about
the diaphragm is it's skeletal muscle so
just like a bicep or tricep or quadricep
yeah
this organ we call the diaphragm was
designed to be moved
voluntarily or involuntarily which is
very different than your heart or your
spleen or your liver which we have no
control you have no direct control over
so there's a particular pattern of
breathing which is two inhales followed
by a longer exhale
may be repeated two or three times
that triggers activation of the phrenic
nerve to diaphragm
and it causes your lungs to bring in
oxygen and it re-inflates these little
sacks in the lungs called the avioli and
i'm running
through this very fast but what it does
is it balances the ratio of carbon
dioxide and oxygen
in your bloodstream and lungs and
basically what it does is it makes you
go from too anxious to calm so if anyone
wants to try this it's two inhales and
it's not the same as taking one deep
breath or doing one long accident i'm in
traffic i'm late for my flight i just
read a crazy piece of news that school's
not coming back in i just saw a speech
from fauci like i just saw someone in a
mask or not in a mask or whatever
and i feel myself getting activated i
feel you know when you feel the tingly
in your chest and start sweating or you
feel that
sort of bout of rage it started come
over you
right you can use so you inhale through
your nose once
then you inhale again at the top but is
my is my is this we'll talk about that
well when you're talking is my chest
supposed to go up the way it just did or
is my belly supposed to go out did you
do all that on a single inhale that's
amazing what do you mean no
you haven't exhaled yet no so it's too
easy i don't exhale let's try it i never
do i've
i get no oxygen in my body the woman
said to me she goes you
are not using even 10 of your life force
so these are the
okay i'm not going to counter someone
else's
no this was like a healer that like i
paid by check
so unless whitney cracks a joke right in
the middle what you want to do is
inhale through your nose then inhale
again at the top
a little bit more then exhale so right
now exhale either one
so ideally it's nose nose mouth and then
mouth
longer longer exhale
eye contact makes me nervous so it's
making me more stressed out that you're
looking at me okay
i won't look at you okay okay wait two
inhales warm today too so
and then long exhale that's
interesting okay why is it what am i
broken uh no
i have a disaster no not at all tell me
that pattern of breathing is what
animals do
right before they lie down for a nap i
feel dizzy you do it do you really i i
when i take a deep breath i start i feel
high
do a shallower breath on the first one
don't breathe in so deeply on the first
one
hold on so go right inhale
okay hold on ready inhale
was that shitty no you're dragging me up
just through my nose inhale through your
nose
inhale again at the top and then
but more like i have coffee breath oh
yeah okay
okay so i'm gonna drown this double
inhale long exhale pattern of breathing
is important because it's mother nate
perfect is that lamaze
is that what lamazi it's much it's
similar to lamaze but
people who aren't pregnant or or and men
who as far as i know still
maybe there have been some interesting
i'm probably pregnant that um
anyone can do this and it's it's
nature's
natural way nature is natural it's
nature's hardwired way
of letting the nervous system these
neurons in the parafacial nucleus
control the phrenic nerve control the
diaphragm control the lungs control
oxygen to carbon dioxide ratios which
translates to calm the fuck down
exactly so it's very important
that people have this tool in my belief
because it doesn't require any breath
work or training you don't have to take
a class
it's available to you at all times i
suppose unless you're underwater or
something like that
now it's not terribly covert like we're
in an argument and suddenly
i start hearing you know double inhale
long exhales right i know you're doing
it
there's an additional tool that's so
passive aggressive
if someone you're dating you start to
fight with yourself right
it's a sigh i mean i guess i roll
optional you know if you don't eye roll
because that's fucking
that's right i'm not aware that oh
you're doing that thing or you do your
breathing thing
i mean a number of important arguments
have been won or lost on the basis of
the inclusion of the eye roll
yeah that's a non-period not about doing
it is about how you do it you're not
allowed to roll your eyes
okay taking a little break from
neuroscience
now a word from our sponsor how gross is
that taking a little break
from me being a crazy person around a
neuroscientist
um to talk about magic spoon i'm getting
worried
that magic spoon is the only thing i eat
yeah it's true the only thing you eat i
am obsessed with magic spoon dude
it is because i grew up on cereal i used
to eat
remember um apple jacks oh yeah
i used to mix apple jacks and cinnamon
toast crunch and that's all i like
cereal i just live for cereal i love
cereal too and i love it
but cereal is really bad for you yeah i
love magic spoon because it lets you eat
like a child
but it also allows me to work on you
know not being shit like a baby
zero sugar literally zero sugar 12 grams
of protein
three net grams of carbs in each serving
i eat this after dinner
i mean it's like a dessert that's what i
do i eat it for dessert at like 11
o'clock at night you don't feel guilty
you don't feel gross you don't feel
like it you don't just feel full no like
shame spiral
um my favorite are the fruities oh
that's a little chill on the nose for me
so i like the frosted ones are you
calling me unoriginal with my cereal
choice no it's calling me gay
the cocoa are good too sometimes i'll do
the cocoa with chocolate almond milk and
it is
so decadent tastes amazing
gluten-free the blueberry ones are good
too don't give don't leave them out
because they're really good
i like the frosted too but the fruity's
definitely i'm a big fan of blueberry
which only comes out on halloween
and that is a good keto friendly gluten
free grain free
soy free low carb gmo free benton did
you just lose 20 pounds
i did do you think magic spoon i mean it
definitely
ain't an instrumental part of your
weight loss journey yes because i hate
eating breakfast this is not even a joke
i hate eating breakfast yeah everything
else also there's not a camera looking
at me but also
um i don't like eating breakfast yeah
and this is so easy to eat and it feels
like i'm eating a treat
so i mean it did help
magic spoon you guys know i'm obsessed
with magic spoon magicspoon.com
whitney grab a variety pack try it today
make sure to use your promo code whitney
to get free shipping magicspoon.com
whitney to grab a variety pack try it
today be sure to use our promo code
whitney at checkout that's my name to
get free shipping
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a hundred
percent happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked that's a power move
benton
that's a move that's a move that is a
power move magicspoon.com
whitney use the promo code whitney for
pre
and free shipping thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring the podcast
can you explain to me and our fans what
italic is
yes italic is a membership that grants
access to over 800 plus quality goods
maybe the same
manufacturers you get a lot of really
fancy stuff but no middleman
you can look like you're you can dress
like a celebrity for the price of
you know one somebody who's not right
well here's the thing all these
expensive brands
you're basically paying for them to like
hire models for their ad campaign
and put crazy brands on it they just
mark up and then you're wearing them
around like i don't want to be a
billboard i don't want to advertise
for some i was going to name an actual
brand for some
man that makes shoes that hardly even
fits
like why is it my responsibility to
advertise your product after i've
already bought it yep yes
just because i'm shaped like a billboard
i mean i want to be one
but italic doesn't do that you can just
go you can cut out the middleman luxury
handbags
cashmere sweaters activewear bedding
bath towels i need some of those
cookware don't need some of those
you definitely need that and even
diamond jewelry
so if you want to propose to me on a
budget
italic is the place so when i have to
buy my engagement ring for myself
um from the best possible manufacturers
in each category be smart don't pay a
thousand dollars for a logo
that's ridiculous it's rigmarole don't
be a sheep all
save your money for more important
things like my merch
93 of new members are breaking even on
their first purchase wow
saving an average of 746 dollars per
year with their membership
i mean think of all the things you could
buy for 746 dollars
one new tooth that's 746 things from the
dollar store
yeah that's a good one
there's currently a wait list to join
italic
whoa but they're offering my listeners
to skip
the wait and join immediately when you
sign up through this link
italic ita lic.com whitney sign up for
the membership
now i get access to italics high quality
beautifully designed products to improve
your closet home
kitchen and more don't pay for those
silly goose markups again
the other thing is this panoramic vision
thing so if somebody has an issue with
public speaking or they're
being they're trying to take in
information they're feeling stressed or
whatever it is whatever the cause of
stress is
this panoramic vision thing is powerful
because it releases the stress
system to the point where you can see
space more you see more of the
environment that you're in
but what's really important is that to
understand is that when one is in the
stress response
remember that internal metronome starts
going
everything outside you seems like it's
going really slowly when you go into
panoramic vision which is not looking
around all over the place it just means
keeping your head nice still
but right now i'm going to do it i'm
going to dial out my gaze so that i can
still see you but i can see the ceiling
and the floor i can see myself in the
environment that i'm in
is the opposite of sort of the um
idea of like being cornered yeah do you
know what i'm saying like when
if if if i attack you and go what the
fuck was that let's say
and you're here if you want panoramic
vision does that mean walking outside
leaving the room changing your position
in the room so ideally you would
view a horizon outside okay when you go
to the beach you just naturally do this
when you see a vista you're hiking you
naturally go
part of the reason why sunsets and
beaches are probably more relaxing
but if you're indoors you can also do
this we've tested this in a
vr format claustrophobia et cetera but i
don't i won't go into the studies in
detail
but you can do this in any environment
even on an airplane or in a car if
you're claustrophobic
if you combine this with the sci the
double inhale exhale
just then it's going to have even more
of a positive effect in terms of calming
the other thing that's interesting about
this panoramic vision is that animals
that are very placid now i know horses
can be very aggressive but
i know you know a lot more about horses
than i ever will but um
but grazing animals cows sheeps horses
they only see the world in panorama
right and what's interesting is if
if a member of one of their species is
you know
injured or hurt you know you see these
gazelles women get attacked by a line
you see these things on youtube or
nature specials
five minutes later the rest of them are
just like grazing around
that we would be traumatized right if
suddenly you know one of us was killed
that location would forever hold a
feeling of trauma and trouble
they are so placid all the time that
they actually have a hard time
staying in the stress right now horses
might be different and we could talk
about that because horses
can actually move their eyes forward
when they enter the stress response
so the point here is that when you're in
panoramic vision so you're dialing out
your gaze so to speak
you are not only calming yourself
internally at the level of the brain
stem but you also start to
measure time differently you feel like
you have more time right right so almost
all reactive states
are states in which we feel like we have
to respond and time is moving very
quickly so that internal memory got that
text you got that email you got to
respond i got to respond
most incarcerations bad decisions things
we wish we didn't say
the imp the impulsivity yes is caused by
feeling that time pressured right and
space pressure being cornered is
i love that example because yeah i think
i'm just trying to put it in the terms
we understand of like
if i'm in a situation where um you know
i'm
an altercation as possible i want to be
able to just have the tools to say
you know when we talk about this a lot
on the podcast is like what happens in
that second between
getting stimulated getting activated and
taking an action and how a lot of us are
addicted to taking an action and being
reactive and then
sending one email can fuck up your whole
month sending one email before you were
ready saying one thing that you
shouldn't have fucking said
right um you know i'm obsessed and you
know we say in in 12-step programs don't
just do something sit there
how do you just fucking sit there and do
nothing as long as possible
you know and it's it's we sit around and
talk about doing something doing
something but doing nothing is way
harder you know one of my favorite
quotes is um sometimes the best battle
strategy is a masterful retreat but
how do you do it and how do you get that
self-control and this is what
you're such a genius um in your work
about but in a
in an altercation or possible
altercation the tools are being saying
of being sang that's nothing that's
latin you probably don't understand it
it's too advanced for you
um but being able to say to someone you
know what i need to take a walk
i'm feeling cornered you know just being
able to say that
going for a walk getting your panoramic
vision activated taking those deep
breaths like
that can truly change your life i mean
to me that is the difference between
you know fucking up a marriage fucking
up a relationship
you know forever scarring a family
member saying something you don't mean
saying it mean whatever or nowadays you
know saying the wrong thing on the
street someone triggers you you say
tweeting the wrong phones are out and
like there goes your professional life
that's right because someone's recording
because
you lost your shit in trader joe's
because you couldn't take these three
fucking deep breaths right there are
exceptions to what i'm about to say but
um what was taught to me a long time ago
by my graduate advisor who was a very
thoughtful
extremely smart and very deliberate
person was you rarely get in trouble for
what you don't
say and there are times when we need to
speak up obviously but
that ability so to introduce the gap
between stimulus and response
in my belief and as a big motivation in
my work is that that shouldn't require
a decade of meditative training it
shouldn't require no one has that
extensive extensive training hr will
have
written me up by that like i need i
would like to figure out the way to give
people tools right now of how to not
take the bait
the next time your boyfriend calls you a
bitch or your mom rolls her eyes at you
like
like how do you not take the bait is
another way to put it well those two
tools will help people calm quickly
they're the fastest tools that i'm aware
of they don't require a lot of training
or anything you
were born with these neurons everyone
has these neurons think of them like
levers and buttons that were installed
in you and you didn't know
because you mainly do the sighing and
sleep yeah and you claustrophobics do it
in claustrophobic environments but
the important thing to understand is
that other animals
more intuitive than us do this they know
to do this they do these sighs when they
get stressed
they know to look at try and get into
panoramic vision or into self-generated
optic flow yeah from their amygdala they
don't know what an amygdala is they
don't care
but they know to do this stuff
intuitively humans are amazing because
we have
two things that make us special which
are
a forebrain that allows us to make plans
yeah
in light of what we know about the past
and what we think might happen in the
future that's an amazing capacity
my dog might make plans but if he does
he doesn't implement them at least not
over a long time scale
right he's just i mean he might have
brilliant ideas but he doesn't implement
it it's funny because it's i think a big
part of what i love so much about dogs
is
my dogs are always so so psyched to see
me even though they saw me two minutes
ago
right they have no concept of time right
they're living in the moment which is
beautiful but they also don't
develop any technology yeah which is uh
you know but we do
and the other thing is neuroplasticity
which is the brain's ability to change
in response to experience
but if you think about it both that
ability to make plans
in light of what we know from the past
and neuroplasticity it's a it truly is a
double-edged sword
because on the one hand we have amazing
technologies planes and
iphones and incredible things
neuroplasticity can allow us to learn
new things
unlearn things develop new relationships
to people places and things
but neuroplasticity is also the basis of
trauma
and neuroplasticity is essentially for
someone like myself who's still trying
to understand it it basically
is to conceit that the brain can change
it can evolve you can make
new neural pathways that's right there
are a couple ways that the brain can
change itself
uh it can add new neurons that actually
can happen it's a little less
common than the other forms of
neuroplasticity but you can lose
connections which sounds terrible
but actually a lot of learning is the
removal of connections
i'm learning so a baby that's flopping
around like a little potato bug or
whatever you can tell i don't have
children
um you know that then you know a year
later you go back and you see
this kid is walking and talking wait
what's the potato butt
those things that just like curl up or
like a roly-poly yeah
is that what you call them yeah i guess
a millipede no i think no no they're
like
yeah like babies are kind of like oh
it's potato bug i mean babies are
wonderful but they're they're kind of
what do you call a box with juice in it
with a straw juice box really i call
them a sip ups
i love the east coast wait wait so so
soda or
i say coke for everything either you say
pop no no no no no no no no
western thing oh that's a midway you say
coke about everything fresca sprite
diet right dr pepper a pepper dr pepper
okay we fucked with dr pepper i'm from
but yeah roly-poly is one of the i think
dividing
factors in american linguistics a potato
bug versus a roly-poly a juice box
versus a sip-up
oh i've never heard it what do you call
a thing that's like a little
uh you draw with it as a kid and it's a
bunch of colors
that's just good it's a thing that
crayons crowns
we call them crowns or browns like a
crown
yeah that's what we call it crayons
cement or cement
sorry i heard something different there
for a second that was fast
seamen are coming okay i'm gonna get
your view
i'm a biologist so we use a different
word entirely
i'm not gonna go down i'm not going to i
mean that's
all the gap between you just saw it
happen you just saw pause that's right
you just saw non-reactivity i'm going to
do this
i'm going to say do you need to go look
at the sunset real quick
um where was i everywhere
okay so a baby doesn't do much their
motor patterns are really uncoordinated
they don't do much
yeah in the course of the first year or
two they go to very
deliberate motor control and behaviors
they start speaking et cetera that's
mainly due to loss of connections
believe it or not pruning away of
connections
so i a lot of people think that
neuroplasticity is all about new
connections it's also loss of
connections right
an addict who is absolutely compelled in
every way
to use cocaine who gets clean and stays
clean yeah
likely removes as many neural
connections that represent cocaine and
its relationship to the dopamine pathway
so can i just say real quick part of the
reason why when you hear rehabs are 30
days
right 30 days 60 days 90 days and they
sort of feel arbitrary in some way but
isn't it 28 to 30 days to make a new
neural pathway or
sort of atrophy an old one said um the
more intense an experience
and unfortunately the more negative
experience is
the more quickly neuroplasticity is
engaged there is something called one
trial learning
right you touch a hot stove once it
hurts i got it you don't do it again
and that's because mother nature wired
us
you know the brain and nervous system
are wired to keep us safe
first before it once allows us to be
happy yes actualized whatever the
verbiage is yeah
we're not designed to be living in bliss
we're designed to
survive that's right we have a natural
fear of heights for instance of depth
babies will develop that very early
without any training
most everything else has to be learned
most everything else i know you're very
interested in this topic
but just to kind of put a little bit of
a bow although we won't um
since i don't know how to tie a proper
bow wrap a present anyway
i won't tie it well so we can leave it
kind of partially open but
the the point is that neuroplasticity is
the ability for your nervous system and
brain to change in response to
experience
i say nervous system because i want
people to really
understand that it's not just what's
going on in the skull it's also the
these eyes the visual
the brain that's outside the skull as
well as in the spinal cord there's
neuroplasticity all over
the gut brain there's plasticity there
two kinds of plasticity generally
maladaptive like after a brain injury
right and adaptive
if we talk about plasticity we'll
probably be talking about adaptive
plasticity
and then there's child plasticity which
is everything up until about
about age 25 right and that happens very
quickly
very easily well that's just learning
right learning is that learning but i
feel like after
25 it turns into plasticity i'm an
expert on this
because it's i i you know kids learn it
they absorb everything really easily
it's harder once you turn 25.
sure it's a little bit semantic but
since you're interested in this and i'm
guessing some of your audience is
um two guys turns out it was guys david
hubel and torrence weasel who
incidentally were my scientific
torrents and weasel he's still live 92
years old
still runs miles a day sharp of mind and
an incredible human
wow i am biased they're my scientific
great grandparents they won the nobel
prize with a guy
wow here at um caltech named roger
sperry
for their work illustrating critical
periods which are periods
from birth until about age 25 in humans
when the brain is very plastic right so
we do call that neural plasticity but we
call it developmental plasticity
like i feel like you don't get points
for it that's that's where i'm going
it's the basis of fire together wire
together which was
if you've ever heard fire together wired
it you just do something again and again
and your brain is reshaped in accordance
that behavior it's like learning a
language when you're
15 versus learning language and since
i'm a scientist we have to properly
credit people a lot of people think
that uh someone on instagram or in the
wellness space develop fire together
wire together they did not fire together
wire together is the
words and important discovery of my
colleague carla schatz who's at
stanford who is a remarkable scientist
she was david and tordston's
graduate student and she was the one who
really
made the key discovery showing that
repeating a behavior or exposure to a
particular environment during
development
makes the brain a map of that experience
for better or for worse
better or for worse then starting at
about age 25 you get what's called adult
plasticity
which does not you're trying to undo all
the shit from your childhood
well neuroplasticity is kind of the
great promise of neuroscience to undo
traumas that's right
and for a long time people thought that
adult plasticity wasn't possible
but a guy came along his name is mike
merzinick and he really
pushed this hard he said look if
something is intense enough or you focus
on it enough
or if you get the right combination of
chemicals released in the brain in
particular
dopamine and acetylcholine and we can
talk about these if you like in detail
then adult neuroplasticity is possible
and the experiments that he and his
graduate students and postdocs did and
now many
hundreds of labs have done have
essentially proven
that adult plasticity is possible you
can learn new things as an adult you can
unlearn things you can people can get
sober they can get over traumas
the ways to do this are many we can talk
about but they're all grounded in a
certain set of principles
you have to be alert for the learning
you have to be focused on exactly what
you're trying to learn
which is i think this is something that
was um so
profound unfortunately this was profound
to me um
listening to you on rogan cause it was
like i'll read through self-help books
i'll go to the gym but i'm ha
i am half-assing it we are all half kind
of focused on our phone we're kind of
texting at the same
time it is very rare that i'm just doing
one thing 100 and then i'm annoyed i
don't get the results i want but i do
believe that we
sort of it's kind of an epidemic how um
uh
our attention is so um
divided yeah absolutely and we don't
even realize it it's become the new
normal
we not only can we multitask but we were
designed to multitask
there's a we can do what's called covert
attention which
is you can talk to me and pay attention
to something that's going on in the
corner of the room at the same time
you can split your attention but then i
might send an email to the wrong person
by accident
about the person or you can bring both
spheres of attention to one location
you can enterocept you can pay attention
to for instance to how quickly you might
be breathing at this moment while
paying attention to what i'm saying or
you can bring 100 of your attention to
your breathing or 100 percent of
attention to what i'm saying
right you can do this in a very dynamic
way what merzenik and colleagues have
shown
is that if you want to trigger
neuroplasticity you want to learn
something you want to unlearn something
you want to bring the maximum amount of
mental focus to whatever it is that
you're trying to
change and that feels like to take
adderall that's
well that's actually what adderall does
it's a stimulant
and it triggers the release of the
neurochemical norepinephrine or
in some cases epinephrine that trigger
alertness acetylcholine is like a
spotlight
and then the key thing is that the
actual plasticity the actual rewiring of
the connections does not occur
during the learning it occurs during
sleep and deep rest
so this is where knowing how to calm
oneself down
not just to sleep better although sleep
is one component
can i just put it in layman's terms sure
like i will if i'm like trying to study
jokes to memorize like i'm trying to
figure out a time when i can go out and
do stand-up and i had to like literally
go back and like re-memorize the jokes i
was doing before the pandemic
and i can't get it i can't i'm trying to
do it and then i go to sleep and i wake
up and i have it
lock and step totally memorized and
that's because during sleep
is when the connections between neurons
are changing so sometimes the best thing
you can do if you're
in an eight-hour workday and you've been
working on something you're trying to
memorize it or
the best thing you can do is just go to
sleep that's right and if you're not
going to sleep
go into a state of deep relaxation of
some kind
just lie there i'm a big fan of this um
process yoga nitra
which is what actually means yoga sleep
you can find scripts for this online
doesn't evolve ambien
it could but in general it involves just
lying down
and it walks you through some breathing
and some focus
kind of body scan type stuff that brings
the brain
into a state that's very similar to
sleep and it does seem to accelerate
neural plasticity
this is a practice that my lab studies
we we take away all the naming and fancy
kind of woo stuff and just focus on the
physiology the breathing and the brain
states
but it's a very powerful tool for
encouraging
the nervous system to learn faster and
for people that have trouble sleeping a
lot of
trouble in falling asleep is turning off
your thoughts which is turning off the
thing that makes you
able to focus so you can see how
neuroplasticity is tricky
it's a combination lock that says focus
and then defocus
yeah and very few people learn how to
master that but if you can learn how to
master that
you we do not know if there are
any upper bounds any limits on
plasticity there probably aren't
what we do know is that it's harder to
learn as an adult
than it is as a child but if you think
alertness and focus to trigger
plasticity and then deep rest and
relaxation
to solidify to create the plasticity you
just keep toggling back and forth
between those
then you're well on your way to
reshaping your nerve connections your
brain
in the ways that you want but i think
unders even just like you said having an
awareness of it like
the person i when i was 25 and
you know the guy i'm dating gets a text
from an exit two in the morning or gets
a nude but whatever it is
and i'm like does that actually happen
oh i'm sure sorry
i'm putting it back on you guys yeah
like yes of course that you know or like
you the phone has changed
relationships tremendously in a big way
good and bad and we can we can sort of
get into the phone and and what that
does to the brain at some point because
i'm of course fascinated by that but i
mean
i'm up i'm screaming i'm crying i'm
slamming the door i'm just can you can
we just talk through what happens
to your brain and your judgment uh
when you are scared i mean right now
we're all in peak fear obviously with
what's going on
um in the news but in our interpersonal
relationships or even for a lot of
people
you know myself included your man
getting a text
for a nude photo at two in the morning
or some text from an ex or something can
be the same as your dad
going oh really oh congrats like not
being proud of you or your
your mom saying or your sister saying
something that's just like you know i
know that
you know my family members can devastate
me with just like one little
passive-aggressive comment or backhanded
you know whatever that where that little
gap in your force field is right
and i just want to just talk to you know
about what happens to your brain
sure when you're on those drugs so the
situations vary tremendously from person
to person but what you just described
really illustrates the fact that we have
one stress response system
one and it's designed the same way
regardless of what the stressor is
and so the stress response is very
generic
so whether or not it's the troubling
text that you see whether or not it's
the lack of affection whatever it
happens to be that's the trigger
the important thing to understand is
it's very fast it goes from the mind
so you perceive that thing it's
different from person to person but
you hear that thing or you don't hear
that thing you're triggered half a
second 500 milliseconds
the body is engaged also the signal goes
down to that
court center your body reacts before
your brain brain
reacts first brain reacts first i mean
there are there are exceptions to that
there are always exceptions um where you
know like a pain stimulus you might have
a defensive posture first then it's
conscious but
but these brain areas in the so-called
limbic system limit just means edge
because it's at the edge of the brain
but you can think about it as like
falling off of your edge when the limbic
system
being near the edge yeah the limbic
system gets activated it sends a signal
of the body
then the body liberates adrenaline so
now the body's engaged too see i want to
start doing this in arguments i'm going
to be like my limbic system is activated
yeah well you see people i always think
well everything i think is like through
the lens of neuroscience but it's like
you must be a dream to fight with
well i'm human you know i don't know
there are people out there that would um
well
we can get into this but projection is a
very interesting thing that happens in
arguments too people can actually
throw their anger into other people's
nervous systems which is amazing
oh yeah what never done it don't know
what you're talking about really
powerful
tool um so the body's engaged the moment
the body's engaged
and the moment you feel agitation it's
because the generic
chemicals are designed to move you the
stress response was designed to get you
to either stay put
move away or move forward so it's either
stay put retreat or fight there's really
no other
fourth option right so the moment anyone
out there
feels that agitation they have to
recognize that their body's been
hijacked
we talk about the brain being hijacked
your body has a great way to put it
so i always say it's hard to control the
mind with the mind you can do it
in your calmer states but it's very hard
to control the mind with your mind when
you've been activated so the moment you
feel agitation in your body
i recommend looking to behavior control
your body to then get control of the
mind
because they're it's bidirectional brain
controls body body controls brain
that's why i suggest things like the
physiological sigh or panoramic vision
things like that because the worst thing
you can tell yourself or somebody who's
stressed is
calm down yeah that's worse right or
forget about getting on a fire or even
take a deep breath which is actually the
will have the opposite effect on your
nervous system it'll tend to ramp your
alertness up even more yeah and don't
say to your girl after listening to this
take two deep breaths right do a
physiological side
go find a panorama if he does that or if
she does that
you are free to introduce the eye roll
to that position calm down
so that's why i like panoramic vision
it's completely covert
so you can for people out there who want
to learn how to remain calm
in stressful situations panoramic vision
is very powerful and in addition to that
for the
which means going outside and looking at
a horizon or doing it right now let's
say i say something that triggers you
you can look at me but you can see
what's going on in the corner of the
room
just stop looking at you basically look
that look i'm still in the picture
delete you but delete right but it start
to include the full room see if you can
see yourself in this environment even
though we're not outside can you now do
that
and then can you narrow your focus wait
what's happening so you can contract or
dilate your right
eye contact makes me very nervous so i'm
now okay so you should do it all the
time i just like went offline
because you're looking in my eyes no
panic because you know what i never
um oh yeah your pupils no i'm kidding no
no i'm just trying to
find out i knew i was i'm that's for
early but i was told this is a
and and the fact that i have not gotten
into nurture yet is
really illustrates my respect and love
for you because i want so badly to get
into the
nurture part of this conversation
because um
isn't it the amount of eye contact you
get in the first couple years of your
life like i just
is so important in terms of your ability
to make eye contact
later in life i just struggled for eye
contact to make see i'm getting nervous
for the longest time eye contact makes
me very uneasy it's gotten better in the
last couple years
but when i first started everybody said
that i looked like
at the side of their ear when i talked
to them do you ever like talk to people
and that you think they're looking at
your hairline or looking at your teeth
what you're doing is a really good
example of exterior reception you're
you're paying attention to what they're
doing as a you know there are people
that seem does it look like i'm looking
at you
uh yeah your eyes are pointing towards
um a lot of people are like you don't in
ophthalmology speak we'd say you're
foveated towards me
oh that's right we're both so afraid of
interrupting each other i wanna because
on this podcast we talked so much about
nurture and
something that they i've learned a lot
of in addiction
um educating myself in addiction
something that we say a lot
is uh genetics loads the gun environment
pulls the trigger
is that fair to say or is that just
sound good for many things i think
that's true look
everybody knows that i am a gourmet chef
i i'm just update her wikipedia now
i'm a whiz in the kitchen i am a
culinary artiste i am
a delusional i am a magician quite
frankly when it comes to
fresh say bread and then i would say
flower and i said fred
your magician isn't watch this i'll
deliver i'll get it delivered
but i can't cook all day i want to and i
can
very well quite frankly intimidatingly
well
but doordash i prefer
oh me doordash is my best friend well i
don't want to cook all the time because
like i don't want to make anyone feel
bad
you know you live alone right i don't
want to make them
no i don't i live with a couple
imaginary friends and two ghosts
doordash i'm obsessed with doordash i
use it constantly
brings food you're craving right now
right to your
door safely they will leave it outside
they won't even talk to you which is my
favorite thing
but they will well but if you have a
problem they'll fix it they'll be like
we agree and they'll fix it right away
like what like say you have an issue and
you're like you know what i ordered
18 wings and you only sent me seven
sometimes
i want to talk and if you want to cause
you're lonely not me
but the people who are they will chat
with you they'll remember you when they
come back there's one guy that has a
that i met
a door dash guy and he met my dogs and i
was like do you have any dogs and he was
like stop talking to me
you sad lady and he showed me his blue
german shepherd he has a german shepherd
that's
gray well we call it blue and he lives
here now
and we're together doordash is actually
a dating app yeah
uh 300 000 uh partners in the u.s puerto
rico canada and australia
you can support your local go-to's which
is really important right now in the
pandemics support your local
restaurants choose from your favorite
national restaurants as well like
chipotle
love it uh some of the best of dates
i've ever gone on were at chipotle
wendy's wendy's oh yeah get them nuggets
right to your door
uh and uh okay sorry my dog is freaking
out cause i'm talking about doordash he
knows that when i talk about doordash
that means there's going to be some food
on the way
the cheesecake factory get yourself
treat yourself
wearing a pandemic order a cheesecake
from doordash
that's called self-care contact is
delivery it's always safe
we've said that already i know i just
want to make sure that's very important
okay
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off their first order of 15
or more zero delivery fees for their
first month when you download
the door dash app and enter what code
whitney and that's a big deal
no delivery fees for a mine did you just
point at me yeah i did
was that an air gun i wanted you to get
that you get that point across
five dollars off your first order of
cheesecake hopefully and zero delivery
fees for a month when you download
the doordash app in the app store and
enter the code whitney
don't forget that's code whitney for
five dollars off your first order with
doordash
benton whitney i'm gonna tell you
something that you're not
going to believe no one's going to
believe it people are going to accuse me
of being a liar
is that that you go to therapy
sometimes i stink oh i know it's hard to
believe i know it is
tough to believe that you of all people
believe it or not
i sweat like a pig i don't even sweat
you know what i mean and i did not wear
deodorant for the longest time because
it
deodorant is chock full of chemicals oh
yeah bad stuff
like aluminum and talc talcum
bad yeah very bad and what is not the
full name not talcum because what it
does is it
aluminum clogs your pores and actually
stops you from sweating and then sweat
comes out other
and then your body absorbs the aluminum
into it but then it's like then you
start sweating other places like your
crevices get swampy
and it's like it's like your sweating
becomes like whack-a-mole it comes out
other places you're not putting your job
around other places it's really hard the
point is
i never were deodorant until i
discovered native native i've been a
long-time user of mine
i see i didn't know that which is why i
never stink how am i just finding out
about native deodorant
it's amazing i used the um uh coconut
vanilla one oh
smells so good i i do lavender and rose
because
i'm a lady i'm a parisian queen
okay but it's made out of coconut oil
shea butter
tapioca starch it's vegan never tested
on animals which is why we love love
love love love
them native will keep you smelling fresh
all day long you have no excuse to stink
you guys let's just get to it
it it's nothing situation more than
smelling someone's body odor
it's rude it's tacky it's unacceptable
it's inappropriate yeah i don't like
this whole like well i don't wear
deodorant because you know
my body well i can smell you what are
you hanging out with
oh that's a thing also like we're
wearing masks and we're six feet apart
if i can still smell you
pull it together native deodorant risk
free every product comes with free
shipping in the us
plus 30 day returns and exchanges
see why so many people love native and
check out over 14
000 5 star reviews wow no one likes
anything
that's impressive sometimes
guys when you're like hanging out with a
guy and they like get in your arm but
you're like oh no and they're like whoa
like what guy is getting under your
armpit i'm just saying
guys sometimes like there's like a fear
response to hide like what are you
talking about
i'm just saying you trust me trust me
there's a deodorant guys you know when
guys crawl into your armpits for safety
i'm just telling you i've had some bad
experiences in the past with sketchy
deodorants
and guys mouths and i've not had that
problem with native
what are you talking about i just trust
me
you girls know what i'm talking about
girls
you girls know when your boyfriend eats
off all your deodorant and makes that
with you
freaks they're freaks girls i'm just
telling you it's i'm just
you guys i don't know that native is
edible but anyways
make the switch to native today by going
to nativedo.com
whitney or use promo code whitney at
checkout and get 20
off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
deodorant yep whitney and use promo code
whitney at checkout
for 20 off your first order
the way the brain shows up in the world
on day one assuming that baby
went full term you know um but a premium
baby is taken out of the little
incubator or whatever they use
and on day one there is a significant
amount of what we would call hard
wiring and that's a good thing you want
that baby's heart to be
without it having to learn how to do
that breathe digestion
all those things there are a certain
number of biases built into the nervous
system based on genetics
maybe and this is still open questions
but for instance
startle reflex how susceptible they are
someone is to startle how calm they are
some babies are just
calm from day one and they're like the
bulldogs of the world you can't
shock them but it does any of that have
to do with what happened
uh to the neurochemicals of the mother
while they were in utero could be
but i think there's a significant amount
of hardwiring there are
genetic programs that come from mom and
dad
that make sure that there's a nervous
system that's a rough template
or map of what that child might expect
in life
then you have neuroplasticity which
allows the brain to be customized
according to experience and we know this
because of twin studies two identical
twins
in the same sac inside which is
important they call it monochorionic
meaning in the same sac
or dichoryonic if there's a little
boundary between those two babies they
can actually have
very different nervous systems compared
to if they're in the same sac
they're identical twins yeah even so
yeah there's all this stuff about twin
concordance it's called
so there are biases and then that kid
shows up in the world
and it's interesting to think about the
relationship between nature and nurture
because let's say that that kid has a
genetic bias to be
more calm and to explore her his
environment in a more
calm way well then they're going to
learn things differently and maybe
become even more calm right so it's
right it's it's what we call a mobius
strip it's there you can't separate it
at any one point
now there is clearly a strong role for
nurturing and
experience but the genetic component is
something that
you know a lot of people are
uncomfortable with because we love this
idea of a toblerasa of a blank slate and
you can just write your entire
neurology yourself or depending on where
you're raised but there are these
genetic biases
some of them like um perfect pitch for
some people have perfect pitch
they yeah they know when a note is is is
off or something
uh other people seem to be tone deaf
right something about the bones in your
ear
could be something at the at the
periphery um what we do know is
every human assuming there isn't some
developmental defect comes into the
world
with the same sensors the same sensors
in the eye
a colorblind person might be missing one
but the same sensors in the eye
the same touch sensors in the skin since
you mentioned weight blankets i'll just
use this as an opportunity to try and
answer your question even though it's
off topic it's a relevant tangent
there are sensors in all of our skin
that respond
to light touch there are sensors that
respond to firm touch believe it or not
little
little things that fire different
electric signals to the brain saying
that's too tough that's nice and you
know gentle or that feels weird or that
handshake feels
creepy whatever it is or tickle or
cold or pain all of those are in
everybody
right and the the feeling of distributed
weight
across big surfaces of our body does
connect to a neural pathway that
promotes calm
so it makes sense to me that a weight
blanket would be used to calm
that would have a calming effect right
like when i am stressed out i put my
great dane pitbull
on my chest and i'm sure it has
something with him but it's also just
like the weights
let me feel so much and holding a pillow
here is a common practice yes
well the reason is that we have an
abundance of the receptors that i'm
referring to
here on our chest so weighted blankets
work weight it
if you like pressure yeah weighted
blankets work for a logical reason
related to the sensors in our skin
that's different than a hug
hug is you get oxytocin from right
that's different oxytocin is this right
the chemical
hormone that's released that tells you
you're safe
it tells you there's somebody there that
would uh protect you
that there's somebody there that's
that's on your side
unless the hug is a little too long
unless the house
is too long and then there's then
there's another molecule which i
i'm guessing that um well you probably
know about it but it's called
tachycheinin
it's a peptide that's released when we
don't get enough social or physical
contact with other people
this is a discovery of a guy named david
anderson's laboratory here at caltex
phenomenal researcher and tacky kynan
is released in our bodies when we
haven't had enough human contact which
we're probably all going through right
now and it increases fear
threshold to fear and aggression so it's
that kind of a great not not the kind of
what's happening with all of us in
quarantine and not being able to
socialize well
tachycanyon releases is that why cancel
culture started tacky kinin till we have
that to blame and we could blame
everyone's just like we need to cancel
yes we do i'm just saying everyone will
i get in trouble for cancelling
i don't know who's who owns the patent
no everyone makes tachycardia and mice
make it dogs make it because we are not
designed to be solitary we are designed
to have a certain amount of eye contact
today a certain amount of physical touch
a day and we are all so
isolated now also just in general like
the the solo
the departure from tribal villages to
now just everyone living in apartments
alone and
um doesn't that tell us on a like
subconscious primordial level like we've
been ousted from the tribe or don't have
protection from the tribe or something
yeah these chemical systems earlier
we're talking about adrenaline and
norepinephrine and all these things that
make us activated
the other chemical system which is the
one that we're talking about now i mean
there are several
is serotonin and oxytocin those are the
things that are released with
thoughts of gratitude social connection
physical touch which is why just saying
i mean a big part of 12-step programs
i'm going to keep
bringing this up because there's so much
um uh
scientific proof of why a lot of this
stuff kind of like works like one of the
biggest tools is a gratitude list if
you're in a bad place you just start
right down
writing down things you're grateful for
and it seems corny and it seems annoying
and it seems stupid and i hate doing it
but there is a neurological basis for
why it works
absolutely gratitude is not complacency
and i do some work with people in
special operations military you'd be
surprised how many like truly high
performers in high risk high consequence
jobs
use gratitude practices to reset
themselves
to be able to lean back into high stress
high exertion type things so
the the way to think about biology and
neuroscience is that
it uses very few ingredients to cook up
everybody's experience
and so everyone we're all very attached
to our own life experience because
it's unique it's unique to us our
parents our upbringing where we're at
where we're going
what we want what we want to avoid but
the chemicals
are all the same you use dopamine to
feel a sense of elation and reward and
dopamine is really the molecule of
desire of wanting to pursue things
and you use serotonin and oxytocin
anytime you feel like you have enough
you're safe whatever that comes from the
weighted blanket dogs close social
connections whatever that is
i use the exact same chemicals but i'm
wired so that
slightly different things release those
chemicals but a lot of the same things
all human beings were wired such that
serotonin and oxytocin
are released in response to to nurturing
physical touch and
connection yeah and tachykinin is
released when we don't get enough of it
right that's a non-negotiable aspect of
our biology
so i don't care how tough somebody is or
how weak somebody is you know to
use you know coarse language in the end
it's the same chemicals that are cooking
these things up
and what's important to understand about
the way these chemicals work is that
they're controlled subjectively like
it's not like you touch somebody and
they kind of well maybe they like
dribble a little serotonin in your ear
that's weird like drool serotonin but
but
it's all internal serotonin is released
from this area called the raphe nucleus
in the brain stem
like it's they uh acetylcholine is
released from the nucleus basalis it's
not like
everyone does it differently everyone's
doing this stuff the same way it's like
they're all kept in the same locations
on everybody's cooking
shelf in the kitchen right until i do a
lot of cooking
it's like babies cooking i'm not very
domestic
i'm not very diminished but i think that
your brain it's like i'm just listening
to you speak in like literally latin i
think that just like
your hippocampus is full of those words
so there's no space for basic things
like a cabinet that's right i grew up in
this
i got in this neuroscience thing really
young and i i'm sort of like
you don't know basic words of like shelf
and
refrigerator but you know you know i've
heard
but when i think refrigerator you say
that and i think of a lab refrigerator
a bunch of chemicals so dark and sad i
like that you just don't know basically
are there people that would agree to you
oh yeah what would you call this
distilled water
sorry if i'm using too much no no no no
no the point is i'm just going to keep
it down you know we think um to use an
analogy like proteins fats and
carbohydrates everyone's probably heard
of those
those are you know the macronutrients
that make up all foods
some foods have more than others of each
of those of course different emotional
states different states of feeling good
or afraid
serotonin oxytocin acetylcholine
dopamine those are the macronutrients of
our experiences
right right and i want to sort of talk
about these
these serotonin and dopamine all these
things that um
uh these neuro chemicals that kind of
drive our choices that drive
what feels good what feels comfortable
and
you know humans are so paradoxical and
complicated in this area because
i like to break down why is my friend
staying in this bad relationship
why is this guy dating this girl who he
thinks is psycho and crazy and etc right
so a lot of times
things that are ostensibly bad feel good
right we tend to recreate our childhood
circumstances if we don't intervene in
some way and actively try to course
correct it we
almost subconsciously try to find that
warm hug of dysfunction
that whatever neurochemical cocktail was
emitted
you know i'm very comfortable in time of
crisis and chaos
and it makes people in my life very
confused i am calm in a time of crisis
and when things are calm
i am always waiting for the other shoe
to drop i get anxious
when things aren't going wrong i feel
like there's a damocles sword hanging
and uh things are about to go wrong you
know so
that i believe is from my
nurture um harvard hendricks talks about
how we're attracted to people who have
the negative qualities of our primary
caretakers and i'm just curious about
like the neurological
perspective on that are we sort of
subconsciously seeking whatever
combination of adrenaline cortisol
serotonin dopamine that we got as kids
you know are we kind of zombies to that
when you see people who can't stop
dating
crazy people people that make them feel
bad people that make them feel jealous
are they just recreating that mixture of
whatever their mom and dad
created yeah those are great questions
so um
i'll approach them in sequence the first
one is this thing about you being calm
in stressful situations i think that
could
there's a neuroscience lens and
interpretation on on that is that it
could reflect the fact that internally
you seem to be pretty high energy
like that metronome tends to be more
like tick tick tick tick than like
to take we know people that's like come
on like you can't engage them
so when the world matches your internal
processing speed
and that match of what's going on inside
and outside are both kind of high speed
it's going to feel
aligned it's going to feel right okay
otherwise it might seem like the world
is passing by a little too slowly
for you right because you're high
functioning this is what we call like
high functioning
it's a reflection of having a really
well developed forebrain
and which is an asset you can make plans
you can do creative work i mean
less but then you end up over committing
yourself and exhausting yourself and
being less hype functioning if you don't
have some kind of moderation right it
needs to be bound yeah but it's not i
wouldn't see it as a detriment but
it means that too much placidity
and calm is going to feel kind of
stressful mm-hmm
because there's that mismatch makes me
anxious and for people that are very low
energy me on a vacation is a nightmare
i've got my clipboard i'm like we're
doing this we're going to see whale
shapes we're going to do this yeah
and for some people that are really
exhausted or burnt out whatever that is
or they're kind of low energy
the world is going to seem like it's
going by really fast that's kind of
oppressive
right and i think people are just wired
differently and the reason i bring up
dogs
is not just because you like dogs and i
like dogs but because you look at the
different dog breeds
and they are selected for this what we
call autonomic
baseline this temperament the the
straightforward way of saying is you
meet my bulldog costello and it's like
it takes a lot to activate him the whole
world must seem like it's going by a
million miles an hour
they are bred to do different things now
i'm really understanding this metaphor
in a in a real way before i was
pretending i understood it now i
actually understand it because when
people
i do a lot of dog rescue when people are
like oh my god i want to get this husky
i'm like if you get this husky is bred
to work
it needs two hours a day of exercise go
crazy
not negotiable doesn't matter what kind
of nurture does it it does not matter
this is just how this thing is wired
um uh australian shepherds everyone
wants an australian shepherd now and
then they get what's the ones with no
tail they're hurting dogs yeah
right and that's the only way they can
experience the world is they get very
anxious if they can't organize things
they get very they get
an australian shepherd sitting right
here would be very anxious about the
layout
of this podcast studio because everyone
needs to get herded together
and the dog will constantly be going in
circles trying to get us all in a group
they heard and that's the only way that
they can experience the world
and apartment living with a couple
someone's in the bedroom someone's in
the living room
really stresses them out some people and
a lot of dogs their temperament is calm
other breeds are bred for an alertness
and an awareness of their environment
it was they were selected for that right
so this this is a
i would say is probably the best example
i can give for the nature nurture thing
those dogs come in
bulldogs come into the world kind of
function a little bit slower than a
whippet
right right nothing against the bulldogs
i own a bulldog i love them
but they're bred for different things
the best you know how intense dog people
are
yeah yeah you criticize a breed if you
want to understand i will say if you
want to understand
neuroscience and the relationship
between nature nurture
spend time with animals yes because
you'll see different temperaments and
spend time with a lot of different
species of
spend time with grazing animals watch
the eyes of a
of a lion that lays around during the
day and then when it hunts its eyes what
the pupils dilate
literally the eyes move forward in the
head you're looking at the brain
the eyes changing in response to level
of alertness
that's us when we're in stress yeah so
you see it in animals best
we are animals but what you described
this
alertness and this ability to make plans
and anticipate things and bring in a lot
of memory
that is the those are the the basic
components of
creative and great works and i think
it's no no coincidence that you're a
creative
in addition to other things that's you
know your job is based on creating new
novel things
that's what humans are good at taking
existing elements
reorganizing them and creating new
things that's what we do
and the the forebrain is designed for
that and it feels like agitation or
stress
but that's also what allowed us to
become who we are well that's the thing
i
uh we always joke that i always say
there's a war on on something there's a
war on stress and there's a war on
anxiety and i'm
you know for me i think because i've
spent so much of my life ignoring my
intuition
and ignoring my gut and for me sometimes
fear and anxiety are synonymous with
that of this like i have a bad feeling
about this person i have a bad feeling
about this situation but you know what
i'm gonna do it anyway because
i think a lot of you know especially you
know women have been programmed
to calm down relaxed or over sensitive
you're overthinking it where guys have
been programmed to
you're being a pussy man up you know so
we have this sort of programming
that has i think in a big way
conditioned us to
minimize and often time ignore uh fear
and anxiety
and so now when i see so much
conversation about getting rid of fear
and anxiety and i'm like
to me those are my guardian angels and i
now am um
very grateful for my ability to feel my
fear and anxiety and i try to listen to
it but i think the hardest part is
delineating what's rational what's
irrational what's helpful fear and
anxiety and what's paralyzing fear and
anxiety
how do you know the difference well it's
same chemicals
always going to be a double-edged sword
remember neuroplasticity is good
neuroplasticity is bad
it wires in traumas it's what allows you
to unwire traumas
you asked about couples in um
destructive patterns or people who are
in destructive patterns of relating
because i'm going to be on i'm going to
be very honest with you when my guy
friends are like i'm doing the
squishiest fucking psycho i'm like you
love it
you love it and you know you love it
because it's unpredictable and it's
surprising and you're getting all this
dopamine from the fact that you never
know where she is and she cheated on you
or whatever
right you know their dopamine is wired
for
well let me um try and explain this um
from a slightly different perspective
so um he's not the favorite of of most
people
um but i i'm a big fan so freud had a
word for what you describe
it's called the repetition compulsion so
freud's
assessment was that when we experience
something traumatic
early in childhood or anytime in
childhood
that we recreate patterns that will
bring us back into that experience
as a way to try and solve that to to
react to it differently because you know
it is true that uh you know a 25 year
old will react very differently to this
the same traumatic experience relived as
a 25 year old
than a five-year-old right they just
have a capacity that a five-year-old
doesn't have that was freud's assessment
what's true neurobiologically what we
can say for sure neurobiologically is
that
the brain circuits the connections in
the brain and the brain areas that are
responsible for
infant parent attachment are not
discarded when we hit age 25 it's not
like oh i don't need my mom and my dad
anymore so
i'm gonna just get rid of that brain
area right those brain areas are used
for attachment
in romantic relationships now that gets
a little eerie to people because
it sounds very edible electrocomplex
right no but you really
really think you throw away real estate
in the brain like oh don't need that
anymore that that's not like the kid's
toy room that then you graduate to
college and go off to a dorm
doesn't work that way that neural real
estate is reused so
so are we just trying to uh pattern
recognition are we trying to recreate
patterns or find comfortable patterns of
like
you know i used to do this joke about
like every time we meet someone we're
like mama dad
like i mean just all the time are you my
mother when you're dating yeah
i think there are elements of that i
mean some people react to their
upbringing by looking for people that
are the exact opposite right so
i'm going to use a an example that at
first might seem a little odd and this
isn't
i want to be really clear is not an
attempt to bring things into
um a kind of salacious or um or sexual
discussion but they're
i want to talk you're in the right place
if you well i i want to talk about from
the bio biological standpoint i'm just
trying to not get you fired i'm trying
to restrain myself
well i mean i i'm happy to talk about
the biology as as we understand it i'm
and i'm
you know i don't know everything so i'm
going to make mistakes as i talk i
i do hope i don't i'll fill in any
blanks that you don't know
let's talk about some biological
hardwiring as it relates to mate choice
let's pick the most let's pick the one
that everyone agrees on can i
can i uh can you quiz me
uh sure although i'm not sure you want
me to quiz you on this one
because what's the most important thing
what's the most important thing in terms
of mate choice
is this a trick question no smell
it's pretty good you're impressed admit
it smell might play a role in it but
what's what's mother nature's punishment
mother nature punishes this behavior
very severely mother nature punishes
this behavior very severely
incest yes which is why when someone
smells bad it means you're related to
them in some way right
so since you threw that out there if you
give a hundred mice
my producers so if you give
your gap is unbelievable so well i'm
trying to i just want to make sure that
i
close whatever hatches we open and and
um but you know
so
i feel like i'm am i blowing your mind
i'm starting to learn where you get your
dopamine hits um
so incest is not
everyone everyone agrees that incest is
bad and there's a
biological penalty for incest that leads
to offspring
leads to mutations that are less
vigorous yes
mating with close of kin in any animal
but in particular in humans
is very bad for the offspring right so
there's
that means that that's the most
hardwired example i can give of bad mate
choice
right that literally means that there's
a punishment
for mating with close of kin you have to
talk to them
so that means there's a genetic there's
a genetic penalty yeah
okay if you give a hundred mice
choice of sorry you give one mouse a
choice of a hundred mice
as a mate opposite sex mate
they will pick the one that has the
immune composition
that is furthest from their own without
realizing why they do it
but because from smell it's from smell
okay
it's through what are called pheromones
so hormones are things that are secreted
in our body act on other tissues in our
body pheromones are things that are
secreted by one member of a species act
on other members of a species
or it can be across species but
generally so pay attention to what
someone smells like
well some of these studies have been
controversial
and this um but there are some solid
data that show that if
women in particular if they are given
say 50 t-shirts to smell yeah
and all of these have been washed in the
same washer
with soap and all that stuff they can
pick out their significant other's shirt
with a high degree of specificity
meaning
much better than chance okay so that's
pheromones in action
synchronization of menstrual cycles
amongst women that are group housed
sounds like animals you know not
is available incest is bad all right
then you think okay well what makes
somebody pick
somebody that's not good for them
psychologically right
so then you have to look to something
that's probably more rooted in
developmental upbringing
and the question is are they template
matching are they matching the oh
you know i had a dad that raged and so i
like men who are very aggressive and
then they end up in an abusive
relationship
because i because this just creates it's
just a comfortable
uh sort of equilibrium of neurochemicals
that's just i
i think it boils down to the so we have
to ask ourselves what are the chemicals
and hormones of
of sexual attraction and those tend to
be
dopamine and testosterone in men and
dopamine and estrogen in women people
think that estrogen is the opposite
of testosterone but actually prolactin
is the opposite of
testosterone and estrogen in terms of
its brain effects we can get into this
but
so people are attracted to certain
people because of this release of this
neurochemical dopamine which makes them
excited it's
it is the the molecule of desire it's
closely tethered to estrogen in women
and to testosterone does adrenaline turn
into dopamine
no but adrenaline can so this is
interesting so for some people
high levels of adrenaline activate the
dopamine and testosterone response and
testosterone in both men and women
is responsible for libido and sort of
attraction so someone that for some
people someone that causes you stress
right could then give you dopamine
absolutely so let's just
let's create a what einstein would have
called a gadonkan experiment was just in
our minds this is not a
laboratory experiment but in line with
this hypothesis somebody grows up in a
household
where there's a lot of aggressive
behavior
and they swear they're never getting
involved with somebody who has that like
hair trigger
kind of aggressive behavior then you
they find themselves and their friends
find that person
in a relationship with somebody who has
that kind of behavior and they feel like
it's a turn on
that they're attracted to that person it
might not even be sexual excitement but
it's
they're drawn to that person yeah drawn
it could be that adrenaline that whole
circuit for adrenaline has been wired
to recruit things like dopamine
and the sexual response when they
experience that kind of heightened level
of activation yeah
they're pretty good data showing that
adrenaline can trigger
testosterone as long as it's not too
much if there's too much adrenaline
then testosterone is is suppressed and
makes cortisol
we make cortisol instead rather so you
could imagine that people repeat these
patterns
what freud would have called the
repetition compulsion on the basis some
early template
that was learned not as hardwired as
incest which
is absolutely categorically without
question bad
at a biological level right i think
almost everyone would agree that right
and the ones that wouldn't are the ones
we got to be concerned about right
right so then uh sorry
but so when people say they like crazy
like they go oh you know he's crazy or
short
they don't people that are attracted to
drama that are always with you know
in some kind of chaos we all know those
people right and maybe
and that largely presumably reflects an
internal chaos that they're trying to
pattern match with
or their life is dull and it's the one
thing that takes them out of their life
of dullness i don't know i'm not a
psychologist so i can't speculate on
that but
the neurochemicals of attraction and
desire are very simple
it's dopamine we think of dopamine as
the reward people always say like sex
triggers dopamine or money triggers
dopamine
it's not it's not so much having sex
or acquiring money it's the pursuit of
sex or money
that's right it's it's the gambler it's
the person who's going to get high
this is where these and now we're
talking about it in a dark way but i
want to be clear
the dopamine system is one of the
reasons why we
evolved to leave the territories we were
raised in and go find new territories to
build businesses to seek healthy
relationships to
seek degrees or careers i mean it is the
molecule of pursuit of anything that
lies outside
boundaries of our skin motivation low
dopamine low motivation low dopamine
aedonia sadness serotonin
is the feel good with what you've got
and when you look at drugs of abuse
you start to see these in their extreme
somebody on cocaine is all about pursuit
of something
right especially cocaine amphetamine and
if you see people who are
cocaine and steroids you're trying
testosterone and dopamine it's
all pursuit pursuits cocaine addicts
love me
i don't know if it's a hair i don't know
what it is i don't have it i don't know
i just don't have a scientific
explanation for it so i'm just gonna
say you have a strong data point is
there something about me that makes
addicts love me explain
uh they are associating you with the
dopamine experience with their mom
i'm their drunk mom the serotonin if you
think about drugs like marijuana or the
opioid system
those tend to make people pretty happy
to just sit there and do nothing yeah
right now i realize there are
there are um some people that because
marijuana is legal in california that
the cannabis crew comes after me with
pitchforks although very slowly
so what i want to say is i mean there
are i'm talking about extremes here i'm
talking about abuse of chemicals
um in all cases but the serotonin system
tends to make people pretty quiescent
and so
and i know couples that are both both
very placid and they seem so happy
together right
yeah they're not somehow they've created
a bubble
where the whole reward system is within
that bubble they're secretly in an open
relationship or
and they're bringing tea to each other
each other yeah they're wearing horse
masks or something
i mean you see this stuff all over
social media the memes
that you see or the pictures of couples
together the sunsets all that
you can think of those as very serotonin
or very dopamine
they get after it monday morning is for
sharks or whatever i see this
yeah yeah that's all just these
neurochemicals different neurochemical
systems
that's right but when people get into a
pattern
of pursuing things that are detrimental
to their goals like they want to raise a
healthy
safe family or they want to be in a
relationship that feels nurturing and
physically and emotionally safe and
they're making choices that are not in
line with that
i do think it's worth looking to
developmental upbringing and say well
maybe my reward system is attached to
exactly the thing that is wrong for me
they need to start engaging their
forebrain and
acknowledge that it's going to take a
while i keep sabotaging myself i'm
trying to just put this in like right
self-sabotage um
people they're making poor poor
decisions and
excitement and sexual arousal are
closely linked
sexual arousal and relationships i last
heard are
closely linked i think that's a fair and
safe assessment
it's not the thing that brings together
two members of a species to decide to
invest resources
are these chemical systems um other
systems as well
plans and things but at its core
the glue is a chemical glue because let
me
i'm going to just say something
non-scientific like
this might not land great but like you
know when you have a really good friend
and they've dated a bunch of people
and then the person they picked to be
like their husband or wife you're like
what her or him that's the one
this is not okay like there's something
else going on here and then usually the
discussion is well maybe there's
something we don't know yeah yeah
there's always like like there's always
the like maybe there's something we
don't know right
totally sort of like what is she doing
that i don't know about is this is she
doing key goals like what's happening
when you're just like that's the person
and you're like oh there's some other
thing going on
here yeah i think that it it's
perplexing yeah you know when we see
these things uh
you know there's another example that's
um maybe a little uncomfortable for
people but and i don't use these
examples to make
people uncomfortable but when you look
at non-randomness biology is very
uncomfortable
biology is uncomfortable non-randomness
so the incest thing where there's a
genetic penalty
um fetishes are an interesting topic
love it
why do so many guys want to fuck my feet
i was about to
i mean they're i don't have good feet so
um
they look like et's fingers so
i'm just saying i know but i think my
training did not prepare me for this
um my my second toe is like is slightly
longer than my first toe i don't know
why anyone would want to
isn't that supposed to be a sign of
royalty yeah thank you
yes it actually gets me yeah that's
that's that's actually been scientists
well
so did you are you gonna take me off
track digit ratio so i was part of a
paper that was published in the year
2000 with a group out of berkeley it was
published in the journal nature
digit ratios are dictated in utero
by hormone exposure whoa yeah and we can
talk about this because i had
implications for
um heterosexual versus homosexual mate
choice this is a published paper
it's also true in animals and i can give
you that story um if you want in
a few minutes but let me um let's talk
about fetishes talk about fucking my
feet
so the interesting thing about fetishes
is um
they're not random people don't develop
fetishes to
lampposts very rare if they do right
right
or paper towels almost all the
fetishes are to things that are
infectious
feet feces corpses
these are like there are fetishes that
are outside those realms
but is the feed from crawling around as
a baby and seeing your mom's feet
i'm gonna make a different argument
which is somewhat conjecture
but there's a there are circuits in our
hypothalamus we get this area right
above the roof of our mouth
that is called the hypothalamus it is
every bit as important as the amygdala
and all the other the hippocampus and
all the other stuff that you hear about
because it controls things like
temperature regulation
sexual behavior it's extremely important
the hypothalamus has neurons that
control
repetitive behaviors meaning things we
want to move toward
the stuff and then it also has neurons
that live
right next door to those neurons that
control what we call aversive behaviors
the
the move away thing right yeah
it was a yiddish yeah i was gonna say
you guys have so
there's some complicated just recoiling
approach retreat yeah grossed out desire
whatever the reason i use those terms in
case people want to go look up more
and um and just to make sure that it you
know i stay within the bounds of some of
the the work on this stuff
so these cir these neurons control
brain circuits that were designed to
either move us towards things right food
sex warmth when we're cold cool when
we're warm
etc or move us away from things that
were dangerous to us
so think about vomit feces feet those
corpses those things are not just
gross they're actually dangerous they're
dangerous from an infection standpoint
and it is no surprise that you have
neurons that push
you toward things draw you i should say
toward you
toward things that are good for you
right sugar fat
reproduction we are a species that needs
to propagate right right et cetera
but it needs to be context appropriate
age appropriate species appropriate all
that stuff but
you know what i mean but also circuits
that
are aversive that force us to recoil the
the no
like gross and disgust pathogen
avoidance so it's kind of pathogen
avoidance so it's kind of interesting to
think that
to reflect on the fact that many
fetishes are rooted
in a crossover between desire
and these things that are dangerous to
us i mean before antibiotics which
everyone's anti-antibiotics but
antibiotics have saved many lives
have cured many infections there are
with their appropriate use
those things were dangerous the reason
we put bodies in the ground is because
decaying bodies are infectious
so there's an uncomfortable and if
people are feeling some discomfort even
just hearing these phrases
that's this that's good those are the
circuits i'm talking about
action right now so things like incest
or or
corpses or things that the reason we
recoil today the way dolls
robots you know like when people look at
my robot they get
freaked out and weirded out non-animated
forms
they say it looks like something that
would be sick or dead don't fuck this
thing the hypothalamus could very well
be thinking
that what you people get creeped out by
dolls by robots by
clowns anything that looks human but is
a little off right
so those are circuits where and i'm not
out here to demonize people's
behavior i'm not a psychologist i'm not
i'm not i'm not judging anyone's
behavior or choices but you can start to
think of because you're asking the
question how is it that the thing that
is
worse for us is the thing that we desire
yeah why does this person go after it
well
it means at a core level it means that
there is neural circuitry that has been
wired up
so that the thing that is supposed to be
aversive has become repetitive it put
into english it means the thing that
you're supposed to say
that's disgusting yeah is attractive to
you yeah and i'm not putting any kind of
moral judgment here one way or the other
i'm talking about what is
safe biologically and evolutionarily
speaking and what is not
what's advantageous for our species and
historically what has been
disadvantageous or maladaptive
so there are people that
like chaos and drama and
it turns them on in a variety of ways
right mentally and physically
and much of therapy much of trauma
release work much of work in the
addiction community is centered around
trying to do two things one is to create
new rewards that are associated with
healthy behaviors
right i mean 12 steps a really good
example where the community aspect is a
big part of it trying to create those
bonds
yes an attachment to be new behaviors to
try and
pull that reward circuitry toward
healthier things
tacky
yeah so much of it is about uh
fellowship
and making emotional bonds and not
isolating that's a really big part of
what why 12-step works
right and move us away from i mean for
an addict
and now i'm lumping addiction to this
but for an addict whose life is going
down the tubes or spent all their money
has lost their job has lost their family
and they continue to want to use
it's clear that the reward pathway has
been linked to something that's
maladaptive
now i realize as i'm saying this that
and people are some people are probably
thinking this is just a lot of neuro
speak for what we already know
but there's an important operational or
kind of verb
element in this not just naming things
but putting verb tenses on it which is
if you want to build new healthy reward
circuitry in any domain of life
relationships or related to drug
behavior or avoiding drug behavior
is is what i'm referring to it's very
important that there's a behavior
involved in moving away in creating new
forms of rewarding things
this is why it's not sufficient to just
sit there yeah and
you need you need a carrot and a stick
you need to push off the destructive
behavior and you need
to create new intense rewards right
maybe as intense rewards for taking the
healthcare reaction
right so it can't be gratitude or
cocaine it's got to be
gratitude as as the the competitor
cocaine addiction but it's not just
going to be gratitude because gratitude
is never going to have that kind of
intense dopamine release it's going to
have to be gratitude
community job pursuit of new things that
are exciting there has to be a mode of
excitement
attached to the thing that you want it
can't just be passive
for the good stuff and active it's like
it's like you know changing your brain
is the same as going to the gym
you can't just want to change your body
without going to the gym you can't want
to change your brain without actually
um having the reward right so it's it's
is a
example although not perfect maybe in uh
when you get sober
after 30 days you get a chip you know
and then you get a reward and then you
get a cake and
it's a big part of it it's baked into
the um to those communities i've spent
some time in the addiction treatment and
trying to release these communities
please go for it what did i open that i
saw you wanting to do what we call a
fixed action pattern involves the brain
now i'm just kidding
there's a there's a subset of neurons in
the rumble
just taking a drink of water can we just
keep it simple um
thirst isn't no i'm the uh
but i yeah so do you fight with women
when you date them
i've never been in a fight with anybody
but what happened is it a nightmare
what's your mate what's the main
feedback you get
the main feedback that i get sorry this
got really personal
like our girl what just like oh so you
don't fucking
care oh i feel like you get that
um can i think about this yes that's so
smart
can i think about that and go for a walk
and get back to you or how about this
i hear you i'm gonna think about what
you just said oh
my god never say i hear you never say i
hear you
are you triggered there's so there's a
field corner there's a neurobiological
rule which is that whatever somebody
says
under these conditions will be the wrong
thing so i'm just going to say nothing
well i do know harvard hendricks says
that uh the way to communicate if you
can't
if if what the person is saying you're
just not hearing you're supposed to
repeat
what the other person says right so i
hear that you're uncomfortable
and didn't it didn't land well with you
that i came home at two in the morning
but i feel you know what i mean right
and you have to say i feel like this is
happening
not you're doing this fucking thing you
have to say i feel like you're doing
this fucking thing
right i i i
you really do not take the bait you
really well there are certain i mean i
just
oh yes the reason i bring it up is
because i think a lot of us are
triggered
by calmness a lot of us are triggered by
not getting an emotional reaction out of
people because we
equate it with not being loved or being
emotionally abandoned or that you know
we project like you said before so
if you're just like calmly listening to
someone it could be like oh so you don't
fucking care oh you know
i think it's just fascinating to and
talking about reading faces a lot of us
project onto faces you know
you might be reading them wrong you
might be half the time we don't even
know what we think about ourselves and
feel about ourselves
how in the world are we expected to know
what other people think
and you know the world is devoid of
any language that's adequate at
explaining our feelings at a really core
level i just don't think that
you know songs are much better at you
know conveying a sense of emotion than
words are
in their kind of written form although
there are some great poetry and books
that will do that
but when someone wants to articulate how
they feel and
have the other person really understand
that's a that's a tough one
sure that's why i think animals are
wonderful because we could
if we can adjust we can actually start
to feel things at a more
visceral level um i forget where we were
a moment ago but i'll just
use this opportunity to say um
that diaphragm thing that we're talking
about before i'm not circling all the
way back without intention here
um i've been spending some time with
opera singers and talking to them
they actually can control their emotions
not just through voice but through the
reverberation frequency of their
diaphragm they talk about this they can
bring themselves to tears or to elation
and that's because the neurons that
control that sign double inhale exhale
and the diaphragm are sitting cheek to
jowl with the neurons that control
laughing
coughing there's a really interesting
study of called
locked in syndrome these are people that
have remember the diving bell and the
butterflies at the name of the movie i
haven't seen it but that's
i think the movie that describes it
locked in as in like you're locked down
right these people can't do anything
except blink they're paralyzed
and they've looked at breathing in these
people and there's
a famous and this is written in a in a
scientific paper
a case study paper but a scientific
paper nonetheless of somebody with
locked in syndrome
and they're measuring their breathing
and then their breathing suddenly
changes
and then they ask the person wait what
happened and they said oh um
you made a joke i laughed and so the
breathing
our breathing is also very connected to
our emotional states it's not just about
calm alert it's also about happy sad
it's about funny
it's about i think i'm choking that's
also an alert signal so
the diaphragm is very important you
asked earlier and i want to make sure
that i answer your question about um
breathing with the ribs the chest yes
breathing from the belly here's the deal
mammals have a diaphragm so they can
bring more oxygen into the lungs because
they tend to have bigger brains than
non-mammals so reptiles will sit there
they only breathe with the
muscles yeah yeah yeah we have both we
can breathe with our diaphragm or with
our ribs the whole concept that your
belly has to extend when you breathe in
and contract when you breathe out sorry
folks
not true the whole system was wired so
you could i can inhale and bring my
belly in
or i can do it this way either way and i
don't have any kind of like weird
yogic whatever control it was designed
to work
any which way and there's now kind of a
movement
in the athletic performance and movement
community of saying oh you know belly
breathing is bad belly breathing isn't
good
belly breathing isn't good sometimes you
need to breathe with your ribs when you
run really hard you're going to breathe
through the ribs
so there's a lot of kind of like garbage
out there about you only use ten percent
of your brain it's like who came up with
that one and if you use your one percent
of your brain you'd be
you have to get it's called a seizure
you know or we can't multitask we can
i would avoid any um blanket statements
like that but
anyway if you're breathing
scientists are pretty nerdy we like
wheelies so breathing with your ribs is
fine
but the more that you can engage the
diaphragm the more oxygen you can bring
into your system
but and aim it i i just want to make
sure that we um
you know tied those up because i
remember they am i allowed to go on
another tangent
you know podcasts are just tangent after
tangent after dance i don't keep your
brain you're you're knowing
you're an elder you're an australian
shepherd you keep wanting to hurt oh no
that's my least favorite breed
you want to keep things organized no i i
i spent some time
on the beach this morning with my dog
and that the um there was an aussie
shepherd out there it would like go and
turn around and look at us
costello was my bulldog was looking at
me like what yeah that animal like
it's totally foreign and you know and
for everybody listening they know like
my
love of my life uh uh sort of passion
breed our pitbulls who have this
reputation for being you know truculent
and uh pugnacious and so for the on the
same token i'll say
that huskies do need to run and they do
have a certain amount of exercise they
need to get and they are very high
energy
obviously they you know need a certain
temperature because of their coat
they've evolved to do a certain thing
but
there are so many stereotypes that are
incorrect about
um these as well on the same token
because so much of it is nurture in
terms of aggression level and stuff so
it's like
a pit bull yes is bred to do the maximum
amount of damage
if the nurture has been abused but it is
not what they're inherently bred to do
they're actually um nanny dogs they're
actually bred to watch children
yeah they're amazing with kids when
their nurture is negative
they can do the maximum amount of damage
i lost an ear like
i i yeah my ear was bitten off it was
sold back on
wow yeah by a pit bull yeah by a by a
mix
yeah wow yeah so and there's no such
thing as pitbull it's like
pitbull is also many areas yeah so yeah
so i'm also nomenclature like in this
area is so important because there's
such a negative association of the word
pitbull like
um to what you were saying before
certain words like can just you know
trigger people's fear and amygdala so
quickly so we say staffy we say pity
stuff like that
trying to sort of change the association
with it
um but i do want to go a tangent on
about some things that
served us really well in the past uh
as as humans and we know they did
because we
our reward system was activated we get
serotonin or dopamine
things like one of the biggest fights i
get in in relationships is that i want
to pop
zits i'm popping all your zips
i'm popping all your zits yes all your
zits you've never had a girl do that
no there are it seems to be a consistent
theme
you're like i hear you in relationships
that um and people have these picking
things right i mean there's some people
there
every girl i know has to i have to
tweeze your ingrown hairs i have to
tweeze your eyebrows and i have to pop
your zits it
is actually like to me it's it's
well we're primates it's totally but we
get i was gonna
say something kind of dirty and i
restrained myself um for you
but i you know it's something that now
seems annoying and naggy and
perfectionistic and nitpicky
but in the past that's something that
served us really really well right well
i think it does still
now i think that um it's about removing
infection from the body
i think if you look at primate species
they groom each other
and we can serotonin from it right um
i i wouldn't be surprised i'm not aware
of any specific stuff when i pop is it
it's i it's like an orgasm for me
[Laughter]
so maybe this is like a fetish oh my god
i'm a fetish
i mean there there's a substantial
community online have you ever picked an
ingrown hair with a tweezer
nothing feels better don't think i don't
think i own a tweezer
we have them in the lab but i would
never use them all groomed um
look i have one of these this is nose
hair clippers i have that looks like a
taser
yeah you're manscaped we got to get you
some merch
um i think behaviors that remove
infection from the body are adaptive
behaviors
and i think there's with adaptive
behaviors there's always going to be two
components we already talked about them
earlier
one is a kind of aversion for something
like we got to get that out we got to
get away from it
if i see as a zit on someone that i'm
dating
or like a white head or a pimple or
blackhead or something it's all i can
think about i have to get it
so it's a strong evolutionary drive
there makes sense to get out
infection from the body and then there's
it sounds like for you in particular
there's a reward
you in your case in your case a
significant reward
from the feeling that it is now ejected
from the body i've even done it with x's
you know i'll be hanging out with an
action i'm like can i just get that
we're not together anymore this is weird
um i don't know where the boundaries lie
for that
but have you had women do that to you
yes
okay but you see how like it's so
uncontrollable but it's even though
we're not gonna
give a more benign non-sexual exactly
like a guy with porn yeah there's no
getting between well it's like you know
i have an older sister i'm a younger
brother and she would she used to say
things like
like oh i have to do this to your i have
to pluck your eyebrows so you've got to
do this thing or you have to i'm like
you don't
do anything she's like i want to she it
seemed like there was like a strong
drive
no getting between me and a blackhead
it's an obsession and then after i do it
i think about it so like i replay in my
head and and there are and i and i swear
i don't watch these but i you know
there's a
youtube is a very interesting portal
into
the human psyche right i mean
why is it that a movie of a shark attack
gets
you know 40 million views and a lecture
from the a world expert on kind of the
history of
viruses five years ago saying a pandemic
was coming no one cared
but right i mean that you know you look
at the there's
the more limbic something is the more it
engages the hypothalamus and these areas
of the brain that are
related to either a petitive the things
we want to pursue or aversive behaviors
or both
and the more people are going to want to
engage in those behaviors
and i think and something you're saying
i think explains a lot of what's going
on when we're
we're also confounded by twitter mobs
we're confounded by
cancer i have a twitter account but i
don't go on there much
i'm not i'm not active on twitter
instagram yes i can fast but not twitter
but
what is a twitter twitter mob like when
someone um
an old tweet resurfaces that was
offensive or problematic and then
twitter jumps on everyone uh uh
sort of gets in their self-righteous
indignation and superiority complexes
and fuck this person cancel this person
there's some a trending hashtag of so
and so is over party hashtag whitney is
over party
and to me it it it's a feeding frenzy
it's a twitter mob where they're piling
on one person i mean
very primitive behavior it's it's almost
like the talent well it's evolved to
behavior because it's on
the computer but it's very the
underpinnings of it are very primitive
primitive and
it isn't basically i equate it to our
modern day
rome coliseum you know and it's we've
always done this in some way
i mean what's kind of eerie is that so
there's a paper published in a very high
quality journal this last year in a cell
press journal um which is a very high q
quality journal house um showing that
beliefs are actually attached to the
reward system to the dopamine system
so when people see evidence of something
they already believe
it's it's like a dope it's like a drug
hit for them
it can't the confirmation bias goes way
beyond just
i see more of what i expect or i knew it
beliefs actually have their own
intrinsic reward
and people out there saying oh of course
that makes
of course it does but no this actually
means that you're reinforcing beliefs
through a chemical system
that leads you to see that your beliefs
are actually
more chemically powerful to you than
other people's beliefs even if it's not
true so if i believe the earth is flat
and i go on facebook and i see someone
saying the earth is flat i get a hit of
dopamine
what is the biological basis for that
like why would we have needed that in
the past
well i mean our you know and i'm not an
expert in human evolutionary behavior at
the level of culture
where i know what thing first of all no
one really understands evolutionary
biology all you evolutionary biologists
out there and neuroscientists
i hate to tell you there is no fossil
record
of neural circuits there are skulls but
those skulls are empty so this is one of
the big challenges of understanding our
own evolution
is that there's no fossil record of
neurology all those skulls sit empty so
we have to look at body form and skull
shape
and infer what the underlying neural
circuitry was so when someone tells me
oh you know um evolutionarily this makes
sense i
i'm on board because there's a logic
there but when they tell me oh that
the circuits were once like this and
then like there's no fossil record
because it all decays and you just get
the skull and the skeleton the body
plane now that can tell you a lot
but we could imagine or hypothesize
that we needed to exist in groups
to develop tools that were beyond the
physical capacity of any one person
to develop cultures that a lot of our
brain structure
is socio-biological and
when people agree in groups there's
great strength to that
there's a if they're wrong well and when
you when you're a dissenter
you are actually taking yourself out of
the resource pool yes you're ostracized
you're less likely to
protect it and it's at a core level it's
resources
right it's the you know we are not
everything is being
is driven to reproduce you know some
people including myself don't have kids
etc but evolution
is about the offspring it is not about
the parents like it doesn't
care evolution doesn't have a mind it
doesn't care about us
it cares about the next generation the
next generation the next generation it's
we're
we're wired to propagate mostly and
to secure the safety and well-being of
the office it's not an excuse if you've
cheated
no in fact dr huben told me we're wired
to propagate
i'm definitely not i definitely don't
want to meddle in anyone's relationships
or or behaviors right i mean today it's
just the neuroscience lens on these
things
that's what we do all day we're kind of
just playing whack-a-mole with our
reptilian brains and our primordial
instincts right and the threshold for
typing something out online
is much lower than the threshold for
actually having to go and have a
conversation with somebody face to face
be confrontational
um yeah that so i didn't know about
these twitter mobs do they exist on
other social planning
moms are like have you like have you
heard um of like people that got
cancelled yeah no
it makes sense but do they is it only on
twitter or do they exist it's not only
on twitter i mean
facebook it's sort of like a it's it's a
pylon it's basically
people and to me it so clearly feels
like addictive behavior like this
adrenaline dopamine head we're all going
to like pile on this person and
you know i think there's this
subconscious tell me if i'm wrong from a
scientific perspective of like
of like the same way when you see um a
car wreck or something like you have
this
need to look and see what happens
because it's our way of figuring out
you know at least in terms of you know
what's in the zeitgeist and what's
problematic and what's not of like it's
our way of studying what's appropriate
and what's not and where the boundaries
are and what we're allowed to say and
not allowed to say
and it's our way of going that person's
guilty we must be safe
right and the threshold keeps getting
higher if you see a horror movie that's
really really extreme movies that you've
seen previously that were really
thrilling to you won't seem as thrilling
yeah right so unless you're a real
hitchcock fan and you're really into
kind of the
slow burn of a hitchcock movie if you
see something that's really intense
mutual horror
the hitchcock thing isn't going to seem
scary yeah it's just the way that our
dopamine system is wired is it wants to
go for higher and higher thresholds
there's a name for it which is dopamine
reward prediction error you can look it
up if you want but basically
you anticipate that the intense pleasure
that
is has an element of surprise and
novelty
so i think also people are seeking
novelty it's very easy to find online i
think most people are familiar
with the experience of waking up looking
at their instagram feed or other
thing on on a screen doesn't matter if
it's instagram or not
and not even knowing why you're there
yeah are you
are you seeking reward are you seeking
to punish yourself and the
i think the short answer is most people
are not there for any specific reason
it's that it's tapping into a great
number of these neurochemical systems
and we've now passed it from learned to
reflexive
which is what the nervous system wants
to do and is that part of building up a
tolerance
is that yeah we're seeking more dopamine
we're seeking we don't even know what
we're seeking yeah but we're seeking
that's right it's mindless it's mindless
it's mental chewing gum
that has there's no nutritional value at
the end point now there are elements of
social media i teach neuroscience on
social media so i'm
i'm they're they're happening how bad is
it my teaching on social media
i don't know you have to ask you have to
ask somebody else um
well there used to be teaching
evaluations out there
and um don't do that anymore they do
they're there is rate
my professor mm-hmm exactly for
professor yeah and
there those are out there i think um
that's not as popular anymore
that was a few years back no i mean like
how bad like what's the bottom line
because i hear rehabs are opening for
social media and phones
sorry oh that like how bad is it to
search online
top line like how bad is our addiction
to social media how bad is this for our
brains i know that's something i think i
think people ought to consider
why they're there and i do think that
our the amount of time spent
on the phone and searching other
people's content is inversely related to
our own creativity and productivity
doesn't mean i don't use these things i
do but great creative works have not
come from scrolling feeds
however ideas interactions getting to
know people in different
communities there are some wonderful
things about social media we just have
to be very very deliberate and very very
conscious of how we're using it and i
think that you know in in something the
way that you define addiction i believe
is a narrowing of things that bring you
pleasure i define addiction as a
through the lens of neuroscience i
define addiction as a progressive
narrowing
of the things that bring you pleasure
and dare i say i define enlightenment as
a progressive expansion of the things
that bring you pleasure
i don't know what it means to be
enlightened but i know that the more
things that can bring me pleasure
the happier and more enlightened i feel
whatever that means and that's purely
subjective and no that's not a
double-blind peer-reviewed controlled
study in my laboratory
that's my experience the addiction thing
is definitely rooted in a lot of
neurobiological studies which show that
as people get addicted the source of
dopamine starts to narrow and narrow and
narrow
to just the exact thing and in certain
with certain drugs like cocaine and
amphetamine in particular
they chemically are almost identical to
dopamine
not identical but they're similar enough
so you're now they're literally
ingesting
the molecule that you're used to use
behaviors to
release in your mind well i do think
it's people who wonder like is
am i addicted to my phone am i addicted
to social media i think a lot of people
uh you know ask me i'm not an expert
like i can't tell if i'm an addict or
not i can't tell if this is a healthy
amount or hell
i think the the i love saying these
definitions because it will help you
understand like if there's a problem and
number one what
you know what to do with it which is
another definition that i love
is um to continue to do something
despite negative consequences
like every day you're going oh fuck i
just wasted another six hours on social
media the next day you find yourself ah
my screen time's six hours ago you keep
doing the same how did i do this why did
i do this
i'll try a different definition the one
that i think of
is look can i be addicted to water
sure but it takes a lot of water
drinking
before the baseline of my life starts to
go down yeah so i think of all behaviors
as they're
either baseline neutral meaning my job
my social connections my finances etc
are neutral it doesn't change them there
are behaviors that improve my social
connections my
occupational goals my everything
and then there are behaviors that will
drive the baseline on your life down
very fast like heroin
is a good example yeah massive opioid
release and dopamine release in the
brain
people's lives fall apart almost every
single time quickly yeah right it's
gonna happen
so everyone can agree heroin is very
addictive
water is not very addictive what do we
mean by that well there are people that
i know that have to drink a lot of water
and they have to drink a certain kind of
water and
etc well if they're doing that it sounds
really annoying yeah well
those those they're not super abundant
in today's society but
um there are a lot of behaviors that
are annoying invasive high maintenance
et cetera you hear this kind of language
but the baseline on their life isn't
changing they're still good parents
they're still good people
yeah yeah they're still happy inside so
i think
if you're asking the question am i
addicted to my phone
or phone behavior the question is well
is your job suffering how much
are your social interaction suffering i
would say you know
it used to be that when people come out
of surgery they would
reach first for their genitalia this is
a well-described phenomenon in the
surgical world right i'm not a surgeon
but friends who are a surgeon like it's
totally true people come out of
anesthesia
the first thing they do okay not that i
think that the surgeon
leaves i'm not a surgeon but i'm i'm
going to assume no
the patient that the patient like kind
of reaches for these
their reproductive organs like safety
it's like of their bite now
they reach for their phone they're
yeah so is that a lowering of the
baseline in their life
probably not does it interfere with like
but it it speaks to the
like really deep and kind of primal
level that these devices are starting to
occupy i mean i don't want to demonize
the phone but i will say this i think we
also equate them with safety
that's the other thing that when people
slam phones and you're addicted to your
phone it's also it's like
but i also carry this around when i
leave the house and i feel safer knowing
i can make a phone call you know what i
mean it's sort of like the fact that we
used to leave the house without phones
is so wild to me
and that's the time where i'm like ah
i'm not gonna over pathologize this like
it makes me feel safe
right there are elements within the
phone and even just the physical
architecture of the phone because we're
not in panoramic vision we're looking
into this little box
that are increasing stress but i also
understand that being away from the
phone is very stressful yeah yeah yeah
so you know it's weird i mean it's also
it's so funny because i
i was um you know uh thinking about this
the other day of the phone i'm thinking
about getting a camera
because i realized so much of my phone
is the camera
like i'm not really addicted to texting
and emailing like i hate that shit
but to me it's when i go somewhere i
have an addiction to documenting things
and like i need to get a photo of this
you know uh it's almost like i'm
addicted to taking photos of things
which might be more my fear of missing
out or my fear of forgetting something
or my fear of not having proof of
something or
you just like photos i just like photos
let me overthink this um there are so
many things that i'm
have we have not gotten to so i'm going
to jump around like crazy because
something we didn't mention
around the fear and anxiety thing and
the being attracted to people that
cause you ostensible stress or you know
i think there's been you know i think
this is why words are just so important
i think
that fear and anxiety have been
romanticized
a lot in you know movies whatever books
in relationships where when you meet
someone and you feel butterflies
or you feel we've i think been taught to
conflate
fear or anxiety with like passion you
know like
what from your perspective what are
butterflies
when you meet someone is that your body
telling you to turn the fuck around or
is that your body telling you like this
is your soul mate because sometimes i
think our bodies
send us signals and we've uh changed
what they mean
because of like romance novels and mute
songs and whatever
well broadly speaking and i want to just
be clear that this is
i know i'm using kind of a broad contour
i'm not getting down in the weeds this
alertness and what we call autonomic
arousal or just kind of arousal and
alertness which is adrenaline
on its own is generally negative it's
designed to get us to move away
if you feel butterflies is that a pit in
your stomach telling you this person's
dangerous okay
i'll answer that in a second adrenaline
and arousal
plus dopamine is desire
physiologically they're almost identical
at the level of the body except one has
this additional chemical of desire
shit the butterflies
are in part but largely the activation
of that phrenic nerve to diaphragm
connection
that reverberation this is what opera
singers are exceptionally good at
bringing into their
into their voice so that you feel what
they're saying if you listen i'm not a
big opera fan but i've been listening to
more of it lately because i've been
interacting with these opera singers
and there are elements to their
vocalizations where you feel something
that's right i have no idea what they're
saying i don't speak italian
but it sounds amazing and you can see it
and if you look at their faces or not it
can change things but so that
reverberation the butterflies
is it's a feeling and i think that
we should probably all learn we could
all afford to better
understand what these reverberations
mean that those butterflies could be
arousal that's meant to say get out of
there
like this is because remember arousal
adrenaline changes your nervous system
and which changes your musculature to
make you want to move
right serotonin changes your nervous
system changes your musculature
in a way that makes you want to relax
okay so
the but remember you throw dopamine into
the mix and all of a sudden there's
intense desire for this thing that's
really exciting some people love roller
coasters for
take two people hate them you know some
people one you have a good friend he
spent you know 20 plus years in the seal
teams
he was a ceo a commanding officer in the
seal teams he hates roller coasters his
wife loves them
okay so same experience
same visceral experience the addition of
one molecule dopamine
changes she likes it he doesn't he'll do
it because he's a team guy and they
he's not gonna not do it they're gonna
be a bitch yeah he's gonna do it
it doesn't tear it doesn't terrifying he
just doesn't enjoy it yeah it's
unpleasant for him
that's what it's like for me i'm just
like when is this gonna be over when is
it exactly
but so i think that most people should
have some sort of practice
either maybe through well-guided therapy
or maybe just through a sense of
intuition
of learning to read these signals as we
talked about in an earlier conversation
offline
you know animals are exceptionally good
at understanding what these signals from
their body
humans are still speculating about it
and i don't have all the answers there's
great books like the body keeps the
score
yeah right thunderbolt i can never
pronounce his name the dutch goodness
the
tough name the body keeps the score
great book forgive me for butchering the
name
but there are body signals that are
positive
right there are body signals that are
negative and learning to distinguish
those
and including the mind it's not body
only a lot of people kind of take in
this
the body keeps the score to mean that
it's the only source of information for
the nervous system
that's as stupid as saying you know the
brain is the only thing that matters
right it's brain and body and so i think
that people learning
to how these things connect for them is
going to be important some people are
more embodied they're more in touch with
the brain body connection than others
and some people are really out of their
body and could benefit from somatic type
therapies
some people are really in their bodies
and then you talk to them a lot of
extreme creatives are like this
where you talk to them and they're kind
of all over their place it's like
they're non-linear all the time yeah
i won't name names because i don't know
these people and i actually really love
their art and music
but i hear some interviews with some
creative musicians i'm like
they it's like two plus two equals nine
for them
you know and it's cool because it allows
them to reorganize elements in ways that
are creative that are new and different
whereas you talk to somebody
who's an engineer or as a math
background or a science background and
they're always striving for linearity
you always said you know i'm like that
whatever that yeah you are doing that's
the thing
because i don't like it always trying to
get create structure
so these are two different aspects of
the mind and i think
there's nothing wrong with butterflies
but you have to ask yourself
are these butterflies of attraction or
butterflies of like
this person makes me fearful yeah and
for the people that say this person
makes me fearful and i like it
yeah you should do a little bit of
therapy before you get involved
or do therapy together like again i'm
not a psychologist but i think that
the questions that you're asking what i
love about them is they're getting to
the core elements of this
push pulling biology vomit chocolate
chip cookies
right feces clean crisp water when
you're thirsty
yeah right the reason i'm using these
kind of extreme examples is these are
hardwired circuits
and then you think about relationship
with somebody that's destructive for us
versus relationship with somebody that's
really nurturing but wait
why are people getting pulled this way
well clearly there hasn't been enough
introspection and linking of the
mind-body connection to figure out
maybe their physical arousal is tied to
something that cognitively is unhealthy
yes my 20s yes
you do know how to bite your tongue
which i do appreciate i learned that
the um through a lot of uh
failures a lot of lobotomy is who gave
yourself i only have one lab
as far as i know i don't have any
lobotomies okay so i'm going to ask you
a bunch of like quick
questions because i have so many more
she's asking me to be succinct i'm
literally no i'm not no i'm not i'm not
gonna let you go until i'm
i don't let people i'm happy to talk to
neuroscience where are you gonna go what
are you gonna do do you even have wi-fi
yeah i didn't give you the code i'm
happy to talk neuroscience until you
tap out i want to uh why does it feel so
fucking good when i organize shit that
is a primordial
instinct i'm just trying to
de-pathologize
a lot of behaviors that drive people
crazy in relationships get your fucking
wet towel off the bed i like i can't
handle a wet towel on the bed
well you just said nature or nurture
well you just answered the question i
was about to ask which was not
because you said i love organizing stuff
and then i was going to
ask how much does it bother you when
things are disorganized
and i think you answered it with the
text i just it's fun and two things
happen number one i get
you know i i grew up without money so i
have a scarcity complex and i
and i really respect things i'm not
materialistic but i respect things i i
value them i i cherish them because i
didn't get a lot of things growing up so
i'm sure there's a little bit of
nurture involved and like i bought this
thing or fucking
benton drives me nuts because he'll walk
in with wet feet on the wooden floor
there's certain things that drive me
absolutely nuts but i'm also a horse
girl and i'm
fine being covered in dirt and shit and
i'll pick up dog like i don't i'm very
i'm not precious about that kind of
stuff i'm fine with bugs and spiders but
like
disrespecting things really bothers me
and the fact that
i just said i need organization and this
desk looks like a fucking yard sale it's
gonna make me seem like i'm a
pathological liar but
i can't i can't tell if it's i feel
disrespected
or i need the organization i just like
i'm more calm when things are organized
and if i'm stressed out
organization is the number one thing
that calms me down not a massage
not a you know just if i can just go
organize the bookshelf i'll be okay
maybe it's productivity and cooperation
make dopamine and i'm just
getting a false sense of control um i'll
ask you a question and i think it'll
answer your question
okay your answer will answer the
question
you have a lot of experience working
with animals yeah do animals organize
their space
yes there you go it's adaptive
maybe that's not the answer you want i
don't organize my studio do you want me
to well
they make a mess would that yeah um
you know they do it to varying degrees
but again it gets back to this um
acne popping zit popping thing
organization is predictability yes
and it frees up brain space for other
operations
so perhaps i should have mentioned this
at the beginning but in addition to
doing interoception extra reception
inside outside analysis of
real estate in uh etc all that stuff the
brain
wants to learn things and then pass it
off to reflexive behaviors so that it
can learn
more things horses are really good at
what horses do yeah
diving birds are really good at what
diving birds do animals are specialists
the human animal
has a nervous system and brain that is
really good at learning things and
loves to learn things some people more
than others but
when we learn we're analyzing three
things duration
how long something's going to take path
what path should take outcome when you
write
your comedy routines you think those up
you're thinking duration path and
outcome it's a very creative iterative
process very particular to you
but once you learn how to do something
you pass it off to reflexive behavior
you don't have to think about how to
walk down the hall because
you learned that when you were this big
yeah so
organizing things frees up mental space
so that you can be
devoted to duration path and outcome
analysis of the things that are
important to you
now we all know people that can tolerate
a mess okay my postdoc advisor
i know i've been talking about him
recently to you offline and ben barris
who has incredible mind just brilliant
mind
his office literally piles of papers my
graduate advisor
brilliant mind incredible human being
her office
was a stye i sometimes would walk in
there i couldn't see her now these are
two
highly accomplished neurology
neurologists md phds
one wasn't the other was just a phd but
md phds members of the national academy
of sciences
one had a family was very functional in
the family life the other was a pure
scientist but
i mean i'm talking high high functioning
people but they had one thing in common
they didn't see mess they literally i'd
say i'd walk in there and i'm like ben
how can you work like this and he's just
like don't touch anything
because i won't be able to find it this
is a nice mess like how can you find
anything i can't even find you
yeah you know he's buying his wall of
papers so his mind was very narrowly
tuned to just a couple things in life
he had tremendous concern for a couple
narrow bands of attention and he was a
little different he was a little bit
on the kind of he was not autistic or
asperger's
he had a lot of you know sensitivity
actually an interpersonal sensitivity
but he couldn't recognize faces he had a
face face recognition deficit
he you know he was different he didn't
see the mess if you see the mess
like you would you wouldn't have been
able to go into their offices you would
have just been like there are people
that just don't seem
to see it but if you do it's hard to do
anything else until that's in its place
so i would say it's adaptive
if it gets to the point where the
baseline in your life is going down
right people who are cleaning and
cleaning and cleaning all the time just
like hoarding is
terrible yeah for the baseline on life
cleaning constantly we say if it's
making your life unmanageable
right if your job i'm running 20 minutes
later if it's harming great relationship
what would otherwise be great
relationships i might have i might have
blown up a couple relationships because
of a pair of shoes that were
left like one was slightly off angle
from the other
i saw scuff on the shoe and that was it
yeah so so i would say it's adaptive
because we see
you're starting to get a glimpse into
the way i think about things because we
see
evidence of it in other species that
we share neurology with humans are
different we have brain areas that are
different but
all animals have brain areas that
control our breathing all animals have
brain ears that control our heartbeat
all brain
areas have have brain areas that control
wanting to get infection out
monkeys lick and pick yep humans lick
him and when you say adaptive
like to me a synonym is like i got this
honestly
i'm not crazy i'm not a psycho i've been
brilliantly
i've evolved to do this thing and it's
why our species proliferated this is
what it's like to fight with me
i go this is how i'm wired it's not my
fault there's like
like the train left the station a very
long time ago in terms of this
and it would be very uncomfortable for
you to try and rewire this and it
doesn't sound like the baseline on your
life is going down as a consequence
your home is very orderly and it's very
beautiful and like that's something to
be proud of i think
remember that one of jordan peterson's
thing was like clean your room or
something like that one of his like
12 rules to life and it was a beautiful
one because it's so simple but it's like
put your house in impeccable order i
think that's what he said because to me
it's a little bit like if when your
house is a mess you're a mess it's like
the reflection of i always i always know
what's going on with me based on what my
car looks like if i've got a bunch of
cans and bottles and shit in it it's
like
i'm probably need i have emails to
respond to i have apologies to make like
me it just
represents everything and there's a
whole element you know that's related to
kind of performance and being in pursuit
of goals
i mean that there's a famous online
lecture from admiral mcraven former navy
seal about
make your bed first thing in the morning
that's right yeah and it's always been
sold oh make your bed cause then
you know that at least your bed is made
when that night no matter how bad things
go i think that's a minor effect for
most people
the major effect of military life and
having a first step that involves
something actionable
in the world is also one could imagine
what you're not doing you're not lying
in bed thinking about all the things
that are tormenting you
being in forward action also means
you're not back on your heels quite as
much
that you're not kind of wavering so
actions and behaviors
send signals back to the nervous system
hunch posture yes
but also forward action of any kind send
signals back to your nervous system that
you are in control of your environment
so and organizing animals want that the
reason your dog or horse can relax
is because it feels like it's in contro
enough control is in the environment
it's sort of the whole pack leader
concept with dogs
if you don't lead they will that's right
because it makes them anxious if you
don't that's right people think oh
they're just really
dominant it's like no you're actually
not you but i'm referring to that
the the passive person you're just too
subordinate they
we all seek is a maslow's hierarchy of
needs we all seek these basic levels of
autonomic
comfort once we have that we can think
about what's outside our immediate
experience
and be in pursuit of those goals it
makes people very confused when
people ask me about dog training all the
time and they're like well i don't want
to be mean and i don't it's like
you know that's your shit that's your
codependent shit you're projecting some
other like
work that out in therapy or whatever but
you know the most
clear and stern and dominant you can be
with your with your animal this doesn't
mean abusive this doesn't mean
hurting them or even touching them but
the more clear you are the safer they
actually feel
they feel less anxiety because as you
said like they know you're in charge
like if you're
regal if you're clear if you're direct
and if you say what you mean and mean
what you say
they feel better because they know
you're gonna handle shit right i used to
work with some at-risk kids and some
non-at-risk kids
it was incredible they were adolescents
and young teenagers and
it was amazing if we had rules they
would resist
but these creative sides and more
compatible sides like
you know with each other would come out
if we didn't have rules they would start
doing incredible risk-taking behavior
and we'd catch kids doing things that
were just downright dangerous
so in the same way the animals are
craving structure like structure makes
us feel safe
i mean there it can be taken too far
right that maybe the shoe like a little
bit off center was a little bit much
but you know and i i have i'm very proud
of high heel that's why i'm very proud
of having a lab operations manager
that is so meticulous like our safety he
hits hundreds on our safety
inspections you walk into our lab you
please don't eat off the floor in my lab
but you could it's like he's that
meticulous and it makes everyone feel
great because you feel safe because we
work with a lot of dangerous stuff
chemicals and things like that so it's
safety it's just basic safety and it's
the thing that
and i know that i i probably over
think you know you know i love adages i
love aphorisms i love
generalizations they make me feel safe
you know just to be able to throw a
a blanket on something every now and
then even though i i know it's
it's not always helpful or
scientifically accurate but something
like the way you do anything is the way
you do everything you know i
tend to go there like if i'm in a
relationship or a friendship or
something and it's like
if you do this one thing like if we're
leaving starbucks and you leave the
coffee cup on the top of the car and we
pull out the coffee spills it's like
well what else are you sloppy about like
if what else are you mindless and
thoughtless about you know
it's hard it's hard for me to isolate
one incident and not
uh sort of broadly paint my brush of the
person's character because my brain goes
and maybe this is just a
primordial thing uh my
you know biology but it's sort of like
okay well so how are you gonna parent a
child if you can't figure out how to
carry a fucking coffee cup like i go
i jump that far you know and
uh i hope people don't do that with me
so i try to not do it too much with
other people but
i i find it difficult to
um you know not go there but also
there's a famous story about in uh green
day on
in their writer for when they did
concerts they would ask for green m
m's like this is sort of um uh
kind of a legend in entertainment and if
there were green m ms at the show
they knew everything else was right it
means they checked the speakers
something's like superstition yes it's
like one little thing because it's if
you went out of your way to get these
green m
ms the way you do anything is the way
you do everything now i can trust all
the other things you did so if i walk in
and the front part of your lab is clean
we now know the
beakers are clean now we're meticulous
that's right i know that
everything is fine yeah the how you do
one thing is how you do everything
i think is admirable i it's a little bit
um i mean if i may extreme
well i i you know my job requires that i
do a
few specific things very very well in
order to continue to progress
yes yes i have to raise money in my lab
i have to mentor people i have to
oversee the science and build good
experiments and make sure that we're
meticulous about our analyses etc
conclusions etc
but if i attended to every little detail
at with the level of attention that i do
to those things i would truly never get
anything done
right so people like my postdoc advisor
and my graduate advisor were extremely
successful
in particularly my postdoc advisor
mostly because he
didn't attend anything else his home was
filled with papers it was disaster he
didn't attend to his nutrition etc
so there are these kind of more lopsided
ways of approaching things
but i admire people that have the how
you do
anything is how you do everything i
admire punctual people yeah
um i'm you know we're all reaching to do
better
that's the i hope i would hope people
understand the relationship between
how these things reflect a general state
of being in the world that if you're
sloppy about
one thing it's likely that it might
carry over i think yeah i mean
yeah i don't know if it's fair or not
necessarily maybe it's my
fear you know do you is your do you ever
get depressed
that you know so much about all this
like does it ever take the magic out of
like the whimsical
i don't know life's amazing like i love
life
i just like are you are you i have lows
like anyone else there days i wake up
and i'm like ah like i've got too many
things coming at me
i don't you know um do
but i don't walk around putting a
neurobiological lens but you know that i
i made a movie about a neurologist who
like wouldn't surrender to being in love
because she just like reduced it all to
neurochemicals
yeah but those neurochemicals feel so
good that's so
true but do you ever like like is it
hard to be in a relationship because
you're just like oh this is just me
trying to not uh commit incest and you
smell the right way
and this is me just trying to propagate
and you're producing oxytocin
i don't know i don't think about it does
it ever take well i think mate choice is
a really interesting one yeah right i
mean i think that
what's the what's what's what is your
definition of love i ask most of the
guests this
it would not be a neurobiological one so
there is a
i have a different mode i'm not in that
mode in this moment where i switch my
brain to just
how things feel i'm fascinated by um
i think robert greene has written about
this by a kind of a seed of something in
childhood
that drew us to something like i grew up
i have this
absolute affinity at a visceral level to
birds like tropical birds how animals
and how they move
i i mean when i was a kid i used to get
dropped off at the pet store and i would
just like
take notes on all the birds you see you
know i was like i'm fascinated by
animals and how they move
i'm fascinated by the natural world and
so for me in that mode
it's all visceral there's no analysis of
it whatsoever now i can tell you that
the
you know the elephant has a j-shaped
pupil that allows you to
you know visualize the tip of its trunk
better than other things in the
environment i know the underlying
biology
dissected a few elephant eyes in my days
elephants that were already deceased
from natural causes mind you
but i don't walk around in an analytic
mode
unless i'm thinking about my work or how
it might
or things i see in the world definitely
i
look at some of those through a nerd's
scientific lens
but in general when i'm in an experience
it's just
i want to be as purely with that
experience and not
intellectualizing it at all but i will
say an intellectual the word
intellectual is
badly misunderstood an intellectual
you're an intellectual
and they just feel like fighting with
you is such a nightmare so an
intellectual
you're like well you're actually using
that word an intellectual is somebody
that can appreciate something and knows
a lot about it
at multiple levels of granularity like
from a very top contour all the way down
to the tiny details
your understanding of comedy i mean
about joe like his understanding of
martial arts
yeah it's amazing right like it's vast
but he's not going to talk about it to
me the same way he's going to talk about
it to another fighter because he
understands it multiple levels of
granularity i'm going to talk
differently among scientists as i do
the general public so we tend to
demonize the word intellectual but
part of being having an intellectual
orientation in life is knowing when to
turn off the analytics side
and just being in the experience um if
you want a real
and accurate data assessment of how i am
in relationship cause that's what you've
asked me several times now
i can give you some i can give you some
references and you can get there and
no it's not harassment you can you can
get their assessment i have been told i
want phone numbers yeah i mean i want
emails
here's what i won't do under any
circumstances in any relationship of any
kind i won't be recruited
into somebody else's emotional state
simply
to validate that state and because you
talked about this the other day
is that called emotional contagion yeah
emotional contagion or projection like
um there are people that when they feel
something they don't like they have to
do what's called evacuative
projection they they're angry they're
agitated so they
scream you're not gonna jump on the
titanic with you they scream at you and
guess what let's say i do that now let's
just use me as the bad example
okay all right so um someone in the room
says something or you say something me
and i'm angry yeah
all right so then i get all stirred up
and you're calm and it's upsetting me
even more
yell i start laughing right so so my
internal
so my internal metronome is going faster
and faster and yours is going slower and
it's making me
even more angry yeah the difference
between us say the delta for the nerds
out there
is getting greater and greater so not
consciously but through some sort of
learning in childhood i now scream at
you or i say something
really cruel or i bring up some i'm not
going to do that
now you're triggered and guess what i
feel calmer
i feel like i got one over on you i feel
why because now we're matched in terms
of our level of autonomic arousal
both screaming right now if you're angry
at me and you're screaming at me let's
put you in the bad
okay that's my operator position and i'm
like i hear you
exactly exactly so why is that so awful
you have to move your shoulders did i do
that and you're like i hear you
all right well um so
it's going to be really angry and
frustrating to you because i'm not
getting
i'm sounds like you're mocking me i'm
not i know you can because you know
at an intuitive level i'm not really i
might be hearing you with my ears but
i'm not really understanding i'm not
matching you and humans create crave
create
humans crave this
matching of energy mirroring or
something yeah they crave a matching of
autonomic arousal which is really just
to say a level of alertness you know
they they we feel comfortable when
people are in sync with us
yeah and some of this online i'm saying
this and i'm realizing i've been
thinking about this for the last few
minutes like some of this online
behavior
could reflect the fact that people are
really frustrated and pissed off
and they want other people to be pissed
off frustrated and it's
they don't even know they're doing it i
think a lot of times this is unconscious
look i'm speculating a lot but
projection is a real thing yeah
so you know borderline personalities we
have splitting there's projection you
know
evacuative expression is is very
destructive it's the kind of thing that
it's an attempt to recruit other people
i'm very disappointed with the statement
no one can make us feel anything that's
ridiculous
we can make other people feel things the
idea that you're going to be completely
says that people say that
no one can make you feel no one can make
you feel anything it's ridiculous
the nervous system integrates what's on
the outside who says that alex jones
who are you hanging out with who's that
oh sorry
i don't know they're sorry i don't know
that's an
alien i'm sorry
i'm sorry this is the opposite of a red
flag we talk a lot about red flags on
the show no alex jones is like a very
alt-right like fake news
okay i don't i don't get into that he's
like
i have political opinions i just don't
voice yeah no neither do it neither but
it's that to me is such a fake bullshit
fake self-help like no one can make you
feel anything like
oh yeah no one can hurt you without your
consent like that's just like
fake yeah there's it's not grounded in
it it's not grounded in any
um reality that that you might be a
psychopath right but that's
yeah i'll put that with fluttershy yeah
not true right but i think it gives
people a false sense of empowerment for
like ephemeral empowerment like yeah no
one can make me feel anything
but then you just are going to feel
ashamed and disappointed in yourself
when
right that not ends up being false i
mean there are entire
online platforms and people whose entire
careers are based
on how badly they've been triggered and
i'm not talking traumatized because i
have real sensitivity for people that
have been
legitimately traumatized but it's all
about being triggered and triggering
other people as a form of emotional
contagion and recruitment
the more autonomically aroused people
are the easier it is to recruit them
into happiness and joy think of a great
concert
or into rallying and anger i mean this
is the
these mechanisms because they're so
embedded in our deep neurology have been
around for
tens of thousands of years and people
are still using them now they're just
using them in slightly more
sophisticated ways
through the internet screaming at you
and you so what
so either way you're screwed if you say
i hear you
there's probably not gonna go well you
gave a good example of a of a
an adaptive response adaptive meaning
good for both people which was okay i
hear you saying
that you're really angry about blank
blank and blank
like no that wasn't articulated exactly
the way that i'm thinking and i'm like
okay well
you know that kind of thing yeah i think
i think um you can say go for a walk
yeah although some people this is
interesting because i've observed this
in
trauma release communities sometimes
when two people are confronting a
traumatic thing yeah and someone says i
i need a walk yeah they're leaving
triggers the other person
and so this is a whole there's a whole
world of
very talented and i have to say if
there's a community that i've been
exposed to that has just
tremendous good intentions and and
and you know putting their efforts in
the right place it's this trauma release
community i'm talking about skilled
qualified certified people doing trauma
release trying to bring people to a
better relationship with the things that
have hurt them and the people that have
hurt them yeah it's an incredible
community of people making that effort
and humans are just now
2020 trying to figure out how all this
works and where neuroscience might play
a role
um emdr changed my life mdr breathing
um there's just so much happening right
now
that's really exciting um i it's
interesting because i i have on my list
of things to ask you about like the
sort of neurology of shout and freudia
like why we get
some kind of sick enjoyment out of other
people's embarrassment
you know is that the german word for
like you know um
and is that our way of the same way that
we get
uh serotonin from gossiping because it
helps us
you know collect information on social
mores and how we should behave
you know it's kind of the same yeah when
i see somebody not
performing well i feel like really
embarrassing so do i
i do not feel like i get no but why do
we think it's like
probably more instead of like if a ice
skater falls it's
the worst thing i i i can't handle it i
can hardly even watch gymnastics
because if someone falls it's just like
it's it's too upsetting for me
but when someone slips on a banana it's
if someone falls and doesn't get hurt
there's also nothing funnier
yeah humor is an interesting one there's
a little bit of neuroscience and
quality cognitive psychology on
humor and humor is often just the
unexpected
yes or where i feel like the comedian is
leading me down a path
and i'm thinking oh no they're not
really going to go there so it's raising
my level of kind of autonomic arousal
like oh goodness
and then they might pivot or whatever i
haven't spent a lot of time
well now i've spent some time you know
joe's podcast and now with you
i think comedians are really interesting
because they have a they know how to
construct
linear things they can build things that
are linear but they also know how to put
these
these tweaks they look at the world
differently you know to be creative you
got to look at the world differently so
i can't really comment too much on
what's known because i don't think
there's a lot known
yeah but it is a beautiful example of
the creative process
of taking existing elements and you have
the english language
for you and you can organize it in ways
that are
trivial boring disappointing or
hilarious
based on just the associations with
those words it's really an amazing thing
when you think about it and it speaks to
just how powerful
the relationship between language and
emotions is
i um close friend of mine he's the chair
of neurosurgery at ucsf eddie chang he's
a world expert in speech and language
and he he told me about a discovery
um i think it's from his lab or maybe a
neighboring lab
it's kind of interesting that our
representation of our hands and hand
motion
is actually right next to the
representation in the brain of speech
and language
and this is because humans speak some
people more than others the italians in
particular
use their hands to speak we enunciate
and we accentuate
with our hands and so these are
primitive forms of expression that have
been lumped together and so i think
comedians are
some have a physical comedy all that i
think it's a vast space i wish there was
more neuroscience on this but anyways
kind of fun to take a little bit perhaps
what we've talked about today
just kind of cast that lens on comedy
maybe a discussion for another time and
i think it's important
important for people stop trying to wrap
this up uh i think it's important for
people to
um you know look at uh you know this is
gonna feel like a weird curveball but
like acting
they say the great actors uh you can
tell what they're thinking with the
sound off
you know so when i think about myself
communicating with somebody
if if you took words out of the equation
how would i be coming off to the person
because sometimes what we say and how we
say it contradict each other and we're
like i don't understand why you think
i'm yelling at you
you know like i'm totally fine what
you're saying and how you're saying it
are contradictory and we're always going
to default to how you're saying it right
not what you're actually saying you know
it's just so much communication being
nonverbal i just feel like there's so
much um distressed caused by
that uh lack of congruence between what
we're saying and how we're saying it and
the confusion that it causes in kids
seeing my mom is saying she's fine but
she seems really stressed out i know i'm
doubting my own reality and now i can't
trust women
and now i'm confused and you know so for
me because i grew up in
um with very indirect communication all
the time it took me a really long time
to understand uh to be able to trust
what somebody says we are very tuned in
to
other people's level of autonomic
sort of alertness or calmness and timbre
of voice
is one of the most powerful ways that we
communicate oh wow
so it remember the the neurons in the
brain that control size are right next
to the ones that control
laughing and crying an animal crying
in pain sorry to bring up such an
intense example start crying
yeah is exactly that you just you just i
don't want to say prove my point because
i'm not here to prove points but
you that response embodies the point i'm
trying to make which is that an animal
crying or wailing in pain
a human wailing in pain recruits an
emotional state in us
and in the same way if you grew up in a
home where you heard certain kinds of
vocalizations that were
anger actually i'll give an example i
was at
this trauma release thing i was
observing and trying to think about how
we might export some tools from my lab
to that community and vice versa
um and a woman said um she said look
i've
enjoyed our interactions and i'm really
glad you're here but like i'm really
afraid of you
because your voice reminds me of my dad
and i was like i'm sorry and she said
but it has nothing to do with the way
your actual voice it's just something
about the the resonant frequency of your
voice just freaks me out
and it was and i was like well there's
nothing i can do about that much right
but
you know opera singers again they tell
me because again been spending time with
them that
their goal is to get the audience
sometimes the experienced ones their
goal is to get the audience
feeling in their diaphragm what they
feel
so establishing a resonant frequency
literally a frequency of vibration
so that the person in the audience feels
the sadness or anticipation or the
elation that they feel
not by what they're hearing with their
ears alone by actually
vibrating now it sounds very like woo
but
the phrenic nerve firing and the
diaphragm vibrating at the same
frequency we are on the same frequency
and that's going to be done
through sound waves now animals do this
so fish have a lateral line that senses
electricity
they can sense electric fields in the
water right
the platypus senses electric fields with
its built they can sense
where things are but also the energies
of those things
right are am i being pursued by a
predator
am i next to other fish that are
um a fish like me is it a fish that
wants a mate or a fish that wants to
fight is it a fish that wants to bump me
out of the way to mate with the fish
next to me
this is what animals do but they feel it
in their body
humans we tend to over emphasize the
content of speech
and this is why online the visceral part
in the intention is completely lost
it's like stripped down so anyway
we can um since we were talking about
relationships earlier i think having
given me your definition of love
all right i'll do that right now do you
have one
where the average resident frequency no
i'm kidding
is similar you know i'm sort of half
kidding because there are couples that
when you're around them i have one
friend in particular and his wife they
just have a new newborn son he's about
one now
and they are delightful people their son
is delightful he's just such a cool
little kid
and when they're together it's almost
like everything just gets better for
them and everyone around them
it's like you just feel good and it's
not about what they're saying it's not
about how they touch each other or do
anything like
who knows what they do behind closed
doors none of my business i don't want
to know
but it just feels good to be around them
because you can tell they just feel
great
as a unit and i kind of hold them in my
mind as kind of the
the best example of like not because
they have a kid it's not what it's about
but like love it's just sort of
they bring out the best we hear these
phrases good definition
and they seem to do they seem to do
very well when they're together or apart
i see a lot of people that are like they
have to be like this
yeah or they have to be like this i
think everybody you know it's different
forever like interdependent but yeah it
is a case-by-case
thing i think so and i think their
temperaments are just very well matched
i
i look at people more or less as
different species of animals individuals
you know and their whatever species
match
they are is just but are you because i
find myself sometimes the more i learn
about this the more i start going like
okay
of course i have a crush on this person
i'm releasing oxytocin and dopamine and
oh god if we have sex then i'll have
then i'll be attached to the person like
i find myself trying to check if their
shoes are off center
like hack my own brain you know
sometimes so one of the
one of the um greatest and worst
features of the human brain is that
it can think about itself yeah yeah
so that third personing
is great and can be very adaptive or it
can interfere with just
feeling in the feeling what we're
feeling i'm not
criticizing your response to that
situation but you're welcome
and i don't think we're just a bag of
chemicals i think that we all should
learn something about the chemicals but
we should also learn to recognize
the states in our mind and body that
we like and that we dislike and we
should ask ourselves in a
very direct way do i like it for good
reasons adaptive reasons
or do i like it for maladaptive reasons
are we supposed to go to sleep and wake
up with the sun
not necessarily sunrise and sunset but
one of the most powerful things one can
do for their mental and physical health
is to
view the sun with the eyes sunglasses
off unless you have a retinal
degenerative condition
for two to ten minutes first thing in
the morning you don't have to watch the
sunrise but
while what it's called low solar angle
when the sun isn't overhead yet so
sometime before 10 am or so
noon if you slept in just do it anyway
it triggers the cortisol
and mel melatonin pathways in the brain
and body to be in the right
rhythms and then we definitely want to
avoid really bright lights of any color
from the hours of about 11 pm to 4 a.m
wow
blue light glasses we talk about a lot
of the pod i've convinced everyone to
buy them did they all waste their money
um i think it's a good idea for people
to avoid bright lights in the evening
and night
and blue blue blockers are one way
to filter out bright light by
where you can still see you can still
function safely you can't really drive
with sunglasses at night
but you could wear blue blockers yeah i
think i don't know i don't i personally
don't wear them i just dim the lights in
my home at night but what about on your
phone
um i've texted you at odd hours of the
night yeah so
you want to dim the screen on your phone
as much as possible
and you also want the lights low in your
physical environment literally not
overhead because the neurons in the eye
that
look that send signals to the brain to
wake up are located in the lower
portion of the eye which means they look
up in the visual field
so i i always say the single best thing
anyone can do for their mental and
physical health
is get some bright sunlight in their
eyes in the morning
if there's cloud cover you're still
getting a lot more light than you'd ever
get from an artificial light
and if you're in the depths of winter in
scandinavia you might want to get an
artificial light to do that
but for the most part sunlight will do
it and then at night
you want to avoid bright lights from
about 11 p.m to 4 a.m
of all colors wear blue blockers if
that's in your practice some people get
you know headaches and migraines we
could talk
i know you talked about migraine the
same cells in the eye that set our
circadian clocks and
tell us when to wake up and when to
sleep have a connection
from the eye to an area the brain that's
in the thalamus
called the anterior thalamus the
anterior nucleus of the thalamus then
projects the meninges which are the it's
like the thick tissue that
the brain is housed in yeah you take off
the skull and you look at a brain you
think it's just brain there there's
actually some stuff that looks like
saran wrap yeah yeah but to get through
that saran wrap this stuff is
tough this stuff is like you have to
like really get there i've had to cut
through a lot of this stuff in my
lifetime and it's
really thick fibrous tissue this area of
the brain
projects there and it can cause
photophobia and headache so if you're
getting a lot of bright lights
yes then the blue blockers might be good
for you because you can't wear
sunglasses indoors
so you want to get a lot of bright light
in your eyes during the day you
obviously never want to look at any
light that's so bright that it hurts
because you can damage your rat now you
don't want i'm not talking about like
staring at the sun you know that would
damage your eye but
through a wit a window it's 50-fold
weaker so try and get outside to do this
even
briefly and then in the at night avoid
bright lights or wear the blue blockers
migraine yeah i've i've finally at a
point in my life where i'm not
debilitated by migraines every couple
months but i remember going to the er at
cedars like when i was like
22 and i got migraines my whole life
like when i was a kid i was the one that
ruined every field trip
i was the one that you know ruined the
disneyland trip i was the one that like
got the migraine and everybody had to
like
you know deal with me and drive me home
and i couldn't be in light and i'd be
puking and i couldn't see and the left
side of my
um body would go numb and wow like
extreme
like super super intense and there's a
lot of things that i have done i have
just a
list of of um like a list
um that i send people when they say they
have migraines i wrote all about it and
i have a whole chapter on it
in my book but the first thing i always
say is just wear sunglasses outside all
the time
and get your vision checked because
that's like one of the main triggers for
migraines
is like squinting triggering um so blue
light glasses i wear all the time
um grinding at night it's a big one like
the lactic acid you produce from
grinding at night in your muscles
and a couple of things that i've heard
um migraine doctors tell me over the
years is that the migraine brain likes
routine
it wants the same neurochemicals every
day at the same time every day all the
time so
it doesn't matter really what you eat if
you are allergic to
sugar or gluten or whatever i'm sure
dairy is not super helpful but whatever
you eat or drink
uh eat at the same time every day
basically yeah so the three ways that um
so every cell in our body has a clock
runs at 24 hours which is
not coincidentally in sync with the 24
hour spin of the earth once every
cycle is not kind of like woo biology
it's like every cell has a genetic
program to have a 24 hour clock it needs
to be synchronized all those clocks need
to be synchronized
the only way we can synchronize those
clocks is with light information
delivered to the eyes
not light on the skin that's a whole
nother business but
that's why the eyes are outside your
head outside your skull that's why these
two pieces of brain are outside your
skull
to inform the rest of your body and when
it's night and when it's
daytime we have lungs because we need
all our cells need oxygen
so we bring air into our lungs and then
it goes to the bloodstream and
distributes we need light
information for all the cells in our
body we do that by bringing them in
through these things we call eyes
and then it's distributed to all the
cells of the body the light doesn't
permeate it's sent through electrical
signals and neurons and chemicals
so getting that sunlight early in the
morning is absolutely key
the next way you do it is with feeding
time
and exercise activity rhythms so if you
travel to japan let's say and you're
totally jet lagged
takes a few days to catch up to the
local pattern but if you eat on the
local schedule yeah you switch faster
if you exercise when people are active
and you sleep when people are sleeping
you know you try and sleep when people
are sleeping you'll shift much much
quicker
so but light is the quickest way to set
these rhythms
without question a lot of people are jet
lagged at home especially now what
they're
endorsing yeah so they're like i feel
miserable um disorder i'm depressed i'm
anxious well
you're jet lagged except you're jet
lagging yourself in your apartment or
home
i have so many more questions for you i
can do a more rapid fire if you want no
we're going to do
i'm going to make you do this again i'm
going to sure either publicly attack you
if you don't
the one okay the last last last last
thing i'm asking i swear
is about ancestral trauma
and there's something called family
constellation which i know is thought of
as like complete like
phooey but there is something
to me to and i don't know if it's nature
and nurture family consolation is when
you sort of learn about the trauma of
your ancestors and learn
what fears and phobias you've perhaps
inherited
heights is something that i my guess is
universal some are
more afraid than others there was that
uh study of
uh where mice you might have actually
done this study uh where mice
um got electrocuted every time they
smelled cherry blossoms and their
offspring when they smelled cherry
blossoms would
recoil uh babies are afraid of pictures
of spiders even though they don't
consciously know what a spider is you
know these things that
we're sort of uh wired to be afraid of
and how it's kind of specific
to people my um ancestry
uh goes back to west virginia to coal
mines and um
you know whether this is just family
lore or legend or whatever like we're
all
kind of claustrophobic and big banging
sounds and sort of
uh we all have misophonia and sort of
you know which
our theory is that has to do with our
ancestors being in coal mines and
mine explosions and stuff like that i
just i'm curious if there's any science
to the family constellation
well there's some emerging evidence that
um
learning can be inherited and these you
know the original experiments were done
in these like
these little flat worms there was like
really boring species but
i guess if you like flatworms they're
really interesting but where they would
shock them
and then their offspring would respond
to shock like
they would learn to kind of pavlovian
responses to things even though
the babies had never been exposed to
that so um
sort of transgenerational trauma in
worms of all things and then there's
some recent studies in mice like the
cherry blossom study
um that some of this could be inherited
in mice
here's what we know for sure we inherit
genes from
mom and dad however those genes are
subject to what we call epigenetic
regulation
so some of that epigenetic regulation
can be in utero so if our mom was really
stressed
right it can cause release of for
instance um
the the adrenals the adrenal glands can
release testosterone too it can like um
can masculinize fetuses if it's really
extreme but under kind of more
normal conditions if like mom is really
stressed the baby might come out more
aggressive
because it has more more testosterone
exposure during development things like
that
um there's um
there's also some really interesting
stuff on what's called genomic
imprinting
we love the idea that we get half our
genes from mom and half from dad
and you know parents always say oh
that's exactly like you and that's
exactly like you or that's like i'm
being
exactly like my dad are exactly like my
mom turns out
there's a woman at harvard named
catherine duloc and she had a postdoc
named chris greg who's not at the
university of utah
and there are others who have done
beautiful studies showing that in the
brain
there are some cells that are
genetically identical to mom
and mom only or dad and dad only so
there are parts of your brain
that very likely are genetically
identical to one parent
or the other so the idea that we're just
a mix of both parents
first of all that's falling away i think
the modern genetics tells us that that's
probably not true
what's hardwired and what's learned that
seems to be a kind of general theme
running through everything today and
it's a
it's a it's a wonderful theme because it
it's the most interesting theme in all
of neuroscience really
because it embodies everything but
here's what we know for sure if
a series of grandparents and parents and
children are stressed in a particular
way
the hormones and the neural chemicals
that are secreted could have a very
profound
influence on those offspring we know
that there's for instance
influenza in the first trimester if the
mom gets a flu
can predispose the offspring to certain
kinds of neurologic
issues later now does that mean that
every woman that gets flu
during her first trimester is going to
have a child that somehow messed up no
of course not
but it shifts the bias towards more
probability that there will be these
neurologic syndromes
so immune infection you know
immune compromise or infection trauma
it's all translated into chemical
responses in the body and so i do think
that offspring can inherit some of this
stuff
i um i meant to raise this earlier so
i'll just kind of
i'll add to this topic something that's
very related i think it's useful for
people
if they're thinking about their brain
and their nervous system to think about
what's non-negotiable and what's
negotiable
what's unique to the individual and
what's inherited
and i think vision provides a beautiful
example so
the biologist tornsim weasel and david
hubel
they discovered this periods of critical
period plasticity won the nobel prize
for that they also won the nobel prize
for showing that
the cells the neurons in the eye respond
to little circles that's the only thing
they see the world is
a bunch of little circles to the eye
that information is then passed to the
brain
where those little circles are aligned
into little lines
so everyone kind of constructs a kind of
outline of everything they look at
all animals do this humans are very
dependent on facial expressions
so all humans have a face area some
people like my postdoc advisor were
terrible at recognizing faces
some people are phenomenal at and now
look at things
none of it matters that's right but
everyone has neurons that respond to
these little dots these little lines
and faces some people better than others
that's all true that's all
non-negotiable across our species but
then it starts to get into some really
interesting nuance there's a study that
was published in nature a few years ago
asking a kind of classic
question in neuroscience that relates
directly to what you're asking which is
do we have what are called grandmother
cells do we have neurons in our brain
that represent
my grandmother for me and your
grandmother for you in particular not
all grandmothers
but your grandmother my grandmother and
it's amazing because it turns out
that people have these cells i have a
neuron in my brain that when it fires
i think of my grandmother or i see an
image of her in my mind's eye
okay when i look at a picture of her
that neuron fires
there's a sort of funny but not so but
really important aspect to this study
which was that they brought in a subject
they were showing them lots of different
faces
and their this subject unlike all the
other subjects had a neuron
that only responded to the face of
jennifer aniston
neuroscientists know about these about
this discovery it was published in the
journal nature which is our kind of
super bowl of publishing very very
stringent journal
very high quality journal maybe the most
high quality and stringent journal
so this particular subject i don't
recall if the subject was male or female
has a neuron in their head assuming the
subject is still alive they're walking
around out there
and when they think about jennifer
aniston that neuron and only
that neuron and maybe a few other
neurons around it is electrically active
when that neuron is electrically active
they think of jennifer aniston they see
her in their mind's eye
so does that mean that everyone has a
cell that represents jennifer aniston
no in fact if i'm talking about someone
right now named jennifer aniston and you
don't know who
that is which is a seems like seems like
a pretty low probability event
but if there's somebody out there is
like who is he talking about they don't
have
such a cell so what this means is that
everybody's brain has certain things
that are common to all of us
and everybody's brain has real estate
and neurons that are
tuned specifically to their unique
experience
okay so i have a jennifer aniston cell
right
because you know who she is if you close
your eyes you can imagine who she is and
what she looks like
okay probably even see it as i'm saying
this that means for sure
that you have a representation of
jennifer anston in your head
as the firing of neurons in a particular
sequence yes but is it one little cell
it's probably a collection of cells and
it doesn't spell
jennifer but there's
i'm fascinated by like you know when you
think of someone like
one visual comes up of them like that
that's right you know and the reason for
that is really interesting the reason
for that is that these cells in our
visual cortex as it's called
this face area have direct connections
to the areas of the brain
that we call the limbic system they're
involved in emotion so
let's say someone was really awful to
you yeah
you have neurons that are strongly
connected to the neurons that convey a
sense of awfulness
and you will never forget their face or
their voice or their anything
yes people that are kind of neutral you
walk past people all the time on the
street you see people online all the
time
you will never need to know them and
your brain just throws out
that's our reptilian brains way of
saying remember this person they're
dangerous they're scary
right so what people seem to overlook in
the discussion of neuroscience is that
typically overlook in the discussion of
neuroscience is that
these lizard brain areas and these
higher areas
they are intimately connected there are
direct what we call monosynaptic direct
connections it's not like you have to go
through three or four different stations
right it's like new york to la flight
it's direct
the primitive areas of our brain are
linked to the more sophisticated areas
of our brain they're not so separate and
so it shouldn't come as a surprise that
when
you think about something kind of
neutral or somebody you know it's like
nah
you see somebody who's really triggering
or that you like very much and it's
instantaneous it captures a whole bunch
of your neural circuitry and maybe even
a response in your body
i won't ask you if you know the
jefferson
example captures a response in your body
or not but lair you just smile
jealousy so there you go so it's linked
to something it's linked to something
and so i raised this example a because
there's experimental evidence in a very
rigorous
laboratory study but what it means is
really important it means that
yes we have a map of our own unique
experience in our minds we're each
showing up to the table
with a different toolkit with a
different filter and a different way of
looking at things
but there are a lot of things the
chemicals and the deeper circuits in
particular of the limbic system and the
hypothalamus
that are universal and that's why putrid
things
smell gross and why we avoid them and
you know unless we have some weird you
know proclivity for them
how do you have so much energy and oh
do you get tired i thought it was a
scientific question it always takes me a
second
um sure i sleep very well um i
definitely
i do that yoga nidra thing usually um i
think you're seeing a lot of energy
because i i love this topic
yeah i love i mean jeff franston's great
too but but i mean
that's super exciting when i think about
you know i think neuroscience in general
yeah i just you know i feel so blessed i
feel like i'm a brain explorer that's
what i do i spend a lot of time in
looking around in physical brains
recording from physical brains and
talking and thinking about
the brain and nervous system and for me
it was like it was just
um you know i teach neuroanatomy i see
it as beautiful
yeah you know i look at a brain like oh
my god that's amazing like look at the
olfactory bulbs on that hyena or
whatever
so to me it's it's thrilling but i think
i don't know it's probably how you feel
when you do comedy it's like you know i
i think i'm
um i've got infinite energy for it who
knows there are other topics that just
put me to sleep right away do you like
doing podcasts
uh i've enjoyed this one a lot yeah and
i've laughed a lot which isn't enough
any questions for me loads of questions
do you have any questions for me about
neurology ask me any question let's see
if i can answer it
uh really yeah do you want to do like 10
questions in a row
let's just like test my knowledge of oh
goodness okay
um what does amygdala mean
oh like what is it it's the fear center
of the brain that oh no not what does it
do what does it mean
why is it called amygdala amygdala means
scared almond oh that's right when i
did that shit
all right let's try another one fucking
math i'm used to giving examples let's
try not only
did know that what is that in my i need
to have been traumatized
when i learned that for it to happen
while eating almonds yeah
um uh what does hippocampus mean
think about the shape i'll give you a
hint looks like a hippo
seahorse but close ah but not quite so
okay
um let's think of another one um
this is like the etymology of neurology
terms
let's see um
oh goodness wait wait wait uh
do i get a moment to think of course
there's a podcast so it's like it's
the times yeah no please people stick
with us they're loyal
right um you're trying to think of a
question for a stupid person yeah no i
just i i'm trying to oh okay
um oh what what type of animal
is a platypus like is it a mammal
is it a what is it it falls into a
specific category
and there's only one other animal and
it's this category
this is kind of arcane knowledge this is
annoying well i can tell you what horses
and goats and all that
those are ungulates right yeah so this
is like
yeah it's like you've got carnivore
herbivore i know it's like what is it
starts with an m it's not a mammal it's
a weird one
this feels all right it's a mom it's a
monotreme
yeah no i mean yeah okay and the echidna
is the only other one
all right and then we'll do one more
kind of word you asked me to ask you
questions
um it's too nerdy even for me all right
uh last one
okay no i got this all right but that's
zoology
neurology okay um
i made a movie about this so i might
know some but
i think i know more than i do what's
that neurological condition called
narcissism delusion um
[Music]
hmm what do you do you know a little
history of neuroscience
i mean no i'm trying to ask you a
question i think uh
i can name the female neurologists that
you
named during this spot guest oh cool
nancy and carla
wow so that's impressive i wouldn't have
been able to do that for knowledge i
didn't have oh really that's right yeah
nancy can wash your collar shots that's
great um i remember their last names
that's no that's really good um anyway
we don't have to wait
quiz me what's that oh what are the
spaces in the brain like the holes like
the ones that have fluid in them that
are meant to be there
do you know what those like things are i
know that benzodiazepines make holes in
your brain
do you need a new ra i feel like i'm you
can
yeah i don't work in your brain they're
called ventricles anyway
you know i know the word but this is
getting really nerdy but i like it
anyway i teach a neuroanatomy course i
teach neuroscience um
uh i'll be happy to teach you whatever
neuroscience you want to know
um uh you could ask me questions about
comedy i'm not gonna know
yeah yeah yeah yeah you asked me three
of those i don't know okay
um be gentle i'm trying to think of one
that are as
difficult as the ones you just asked me
those would be like what was the name of
steve martin's first special or
something i don't even know that
that would be arcane who is a
yeah this is hard you're right
i think it's because like rote memory
for like what is what
is not actually how your brain works and
it's also not how my brain works i'm
good at memorizing things but
more what we really try to emphasize
today is like processes thinking about
like
logic and process how things fit
together and that's actually much more
useful yeah than memorizing long lists
of names or
names of things it's actually to know
that a platypus is a monitoring is
totally useless your hippocampus is
smart
and just not not yet can you remember
your childhood phone number
202 well well i do you sure you still
want to give this out
yeah no i'll do this my mom's was after
my parents got divorced which is a
traumatic event which might have been
why i remembered better it was
three eight 202-625-7238 totally useless
now unless the number still exists
i can do it from 202 two three
seven seven eight four two
like i could do it if you gave it to me
i could do by muscle memory so that's
incredible right because how long ago
was
that number active
i guess 30 years but you pass numbers
every day yeah that you don't so
i mean that's stored in your brain it's
occupying real estate so
knowing some names of things in
neuroscience and what they mean in
amygdala zombies
it's useless yeah i teach in anatomy
it's useful for me it's useless so
so you get an a for adaptable for
adaptability of knowledge
you got enough sort of wrote memory but
rote memory is useless in many cases is
there anything to say uh
uh jay-z says if you want to memorize
something you have to say it 18 times
is there any did he say well he said
he said something about like i remember
this guy interviewed him and was like
how do you memorize your
lyrics or your songs whatever you said
you just saved 18 times and i think
there was supposedly some kind of logic
to that
i think the more attention you can bring
to something um
the fewer repetitions it requires yeah
why should i why do i know all the songs
from an alanis morissette song that i
haven't heard in
20 years because they were they get they
grabbed some emotional state in you
or the rhythm is easily encoded so that
there was acetylcholine turned on in
your brain at the time of encoding
it was because they had a acetylcholine
is like a highlighter it was like this
is important
and you didn't have to consciously
decide your brain's like you know
people will never forget that there's a
guy named fauci who has something to do
with this covet communication thing ever
his name is forever embedded in your
brain like him or hate him his brain is
for
his name is forever embedded in your
brain you cannot expunge that unless you
get brain damage and you damage your
hepatitis because of how much
acetylcholine we're producing right now
it was squared in time of stress it was
coupled to a time when we were paying
attention
that's how the brain works i could do
this all day and i frankly might
i'm tempted this is my dream
so what do you want from people like
follow on instagram oh i think
in general you asked me a lot of
personal questions
or you tried um what do i want you can
really bob and weave
his uh instagram is amazing he does
these videos just on little things here
and there
i'm gonna make you get on the community
app and give out your phone number to
everybody
um so you can start targeting videos and
sending things out to people more
specifically
um but your instagram is amazing thank
you yeah i've really enjoyed teaching
neuroscience on instagram so it's
huberman lab
and i do some descriptions of
neuroscience and psychology and biology
a lot of the kinds of things i was
talking about today but also a lot of
actionable tools
as they relate to stress management and
sleep and light and
i host people on there like experts in
um
sleep and circadian rhythm shift work
autism and alzheimer's people like that
are going to be coming on people from my
community
i'll do it um perfect fine you know
perfect so
um yeah that's where people can find me
and um i'm pretty
easily my email and stuff is pretty
easily found on the web what
yeah it's just the virtu it's just the
way academics exist in the world you
know
finally why don't you tell everyone
since we um
mentioned in the beginning but then
ignored it of our
how we met or how we are from past
so right this is the second time we've
met
with a with a uh a gap in between of
three years i always have a microphone
in front of me
um three years ago on new year's i was
in portland visiting friends
and i went to go see you do stand up
that night it was new year's eve and who
i a woman who i thought was your twin
sister not because you looked
exactly alike but because you told
everybody she was your twin sister
jumped up out of the audience and got on
stage with you and
that was kind of the closing act but
anyway the act was super funny and
it wasn't a closing act it was a
surprise to me too oh wait i had no idea
she was going to be i thought
no i had never met her before i thought
it was all right i'm totally confused no
this is wild women are confusing i know
it's a nightmare
i went to portland was performing on new
year's eve i think i was running a
special this must have been my hbo
special or something i think i was
dating someone in portland at the time
we all make mistakes
and uh it was a mistake because of who
they were because they were in portland
i happen to i have been in defense of
portland i love portland yeah
i haven't been there recently i know
it's a city that's struggling with a lot
of issues right now but well apparently
it's not that
big of a thing apparently the news is
kind of blowing it away i have to assume
those cameras don't extend across all
the blocks and
yeah it feels like it's it's a little
click-baity at this point but no i love
portland um very deeply and
so uh and the crowds are just so fucking
smart and great so i think i went there
because i was trying to run my special
right before i shot it because
portland's always just a great judge
like they're smart
uh they're incisive but they still like
to have fun and party and they don't
take themselves too seriously so it's a
great place to run a special
i was doing new year's shows are tough
like it's a lot of pressure yeah people
want the crescendo end to their year
and you have to like save marriages in
that show like this is like
like you can tell there's so much
pressure on you to be
a great you know uh performance for a
date
you know like it's just like they've
paid money it's their new year's you
know so it's like always just like a
little bit stressful to do new year's
shows
and i show up to the venue and i'm like
i'm a little bit like dressed up
because it's a new year's show and i
walk in and the bouncer looks at me and
it's like what are you doing and i was
like what do you mean what are you doing
like what are you talking about he's
like what are you doing here and i was
like what do you mean what am i doing
here that's my show what are you talking
about and he was so
weirded out and he was so aggressive
with me and i didn't understand what was
going on
and then i go upstairs and the second
mouse was like how did why are you in
this room and i was like what is
happening like it was the other
i was yeah i was so like why is everyone
asking me what i'm doing and where i'm
going and people look
like they had seen a ghost when they saw
me walk in and then
what i go on stage and new year's eve
shows never go particularly well so i'm
not convinced
it was a really good show thank you i
didn't know that we were gonna interact
later three years later
how were you close to the front i was
right up front really yeah
and i didn't make fun of you no i didn't
talk to you at all i was no
i was prepared for you to do that
because i've been to one or two other
comedy shows and you're
shocked i was right there yeah maybe
you're in panoramic vision
wow oh maybe maybe yeah no i would have
said because i would have been like what
do you do and you've been like a
neurologist and i would have been like
oh my god you like are
like we would have had this discussion
but then it was sat down because you
look like
a marvel scientist you look like a like
neurologist yes a neurologist like in a
marvel movie you know what i mean that's
just what you look like too so
i'm sure i would have not believed that
you were in religious but
so i get on stage and i don't know
what's happening i'm like going to get a
drink of water or something and then a
girl just yells out she's like
our friend looks exactly like you and i
was like okay and for some reason maybe
it's because it was new year's eve and
you know the vibe was good and um i was
like all right fine just have her come
up here
you know when people tell me that i look
like them and always ends up hurting my
feelings but i was just like come up
come on and she came up and
truly you look similar i wouldn't say
you were identical twins
maybe you were dichorionic not
monochorionic transmembrane
yes i do i do remember that no no i
wasn't producing acetylcholine i don't
remember
but um and she came up and it was such a
cra and i mean the audience like went
crazy i had never seen her before i had
and the bouncers had seen her walk in
and then seen me walk in five minutes
later
also that night her hair was done
similar to yours and like it was
didn't i make her get on stage and like
get out in the microwave and you guys
took a picture together
and i was convinced that she was
actually your twin sister
because you said so no you're like it's
my twin
and then i was like oh i guess they're
twins and then the person that i was at
maybe i had met her before i think she
came to my book
a book signing like a couple years prior
so maybe by the time you saw i had met
her before and then
two days later or something we were
talking about it the person went to the
show with and they were like you guys
were like obsessed with me
but wow okay the person i went with was
that person you were just talking about
how pretty i am no all right well so be
i i'm a nascent fan of
comedy all right i'll just say it i
didn't know who you were before that
night
i'm sorry i didn't know i didn't know
i'm a scientist i didn't know
i i knew very few like i knew who lenny
bruce was you're have a campus
like eddie murphy like i i've been in a
lab a lot of years
but the person that i was with at the
time was like
really excited about your work and so i
got tickets and that was so that was the
first
yeah i mean people have to come to the
table sooner or later yeah
yeah no i get a lot of guys that meet me
for the first time because their girl
like drags them to come see me it's like
you have to come see whitney
and they're like i didn't want to i
really did not want to see a female
comic and then
the show was great i became a fan i
thought that was your twin sister until
two days later
the person i was there with revealed to
me that oh no that wasn't actually her
sister that was just a spontaneous thing
and it took me a couple minutes to
really adjust because i had to reframe
all the stuff that had happened that's
weird i mean i mean it wasn't like
hugely impactful in my life but i
attached it all you think it attached
enough i didn't attach enough to it that
it kind of threw me for a loop
[Laughter]
it was a really funny show and then and
then three years later
i think it was after um the rogan
podcast and you asked a question and we
started talking about neuroscience
well actually we met because my
therapist who hates everyone told me
about you
do you realize that that probably means
that she hates me is that what your no
she loves you
oh okay pot twist the way the way you
she thinks everyone's full of shit she's
like don't read that self-help book that
one's not true that's not real science
that's not attachment strategy like
she's constantly like debunking a lot of
the things that i
you know um i'm exploring and she's like
don't read that don't do that that
doesn't work that doesn't make sense
there's some crazy stuff out there
there's some crazy shit out there
and i certainly don't have all the
answers i just happen to put a
scientific lens on no but she loves you
and she told me to start following you
on instagram okay well whoever she is
thank you and um i'm glad that you did
because this was yeah i don't think that
i don't think she wants people to
publicly know
she's my therapist um probably
yeah i work with whitney cummings um
that makes you that makes you the that
makes you the latest test of whether or
not she could
depending on how well you're doing or
not that's her i don't think she
wanted me to be her like storefront i
don't think she wants me to be
the example of her work it's a lot of
pressure on you too because if you don't
if something happens oh yeah yeah i'm
not gonna say but um
so um follow him uh watch uh the rogan
podcast stuff if you have not already it
was so informative so clear
you're so good at doing this i hope
you'll still um how many videos a week
are you doing
i try and do two or three weeks some are
longer and they take longer to digest
yeah there's some you know it's
impossible to have a really good
discussion about science without
including the names of some
brain areas and things like that and i
believe you know there's a famous
scientist
max delbrook that said assume zero
knowledge and infinite intelligence
i'm not sure i completely agree with
that but in teaching i just assume
people don't know
anything about the topic so they can
show up without any prior knowledge but
that if they're delivered
the information in a way that's
reasonable and thoughtful that hopefully
they'll take away some kernels
such a fan what a treat i end these very
awkwardly
well i'm a fan as well so thank you okay
thank you everybody
don't ride elephants love you bye